how's it going everybody last night we
had a scheduling error and uh the show
ended up getting canceled but it's all
right because it's a Lydia's birthday so
she got the night off happy birthday
thank you guys thank you I appreciate
that I really appreciate that my
co-workers threw me a party this is my
favorite gift that I got it's by ebermex
candy it's a good one Reynolds it's
called stamped for kids and I'm gonna
read it and get back to you guys yeah
it's anti-racism for children that's
right because because there's not enough
critical race applied principles in our
schools so it's a good thing that ibram
has written a book for children maybe
you know that's a it's an important
thing it's like communist for kids where
you spell it with a K right yeah yeah
I'm surprised they're not uh publishing
the manifesto with pop-up book versions
yeah yeah honestly we'll get the
augmented reality yeah I know you want
to have kids and whatnot it'll be good
for you to have that book in Your
Arsenal for you yeah I'm excited I'm
gonna go through it and like make notes
and everything be good good for you suck
it up Sheamus what what I want to defund
the police and then spend seventy
thousand dollars on private security for
myself I'm gonna do it and I'll spend
two hundred thousand dollars if I have
to you know why because I'm important
because I'm doing the hard work I'm the
one I'm the only one who can save these
people what stage of capitalism is this
okay they're defunding the police in
paying no thousands not their own
private security Jamie Sheamus yeah my
theatrics may have been only slightly
you actually I thought you're serious
that is almost a Verbatim quote from
Corey Bush she is a progressive she was
sleeping on the steps at the Capitol
because of the eviction moratorium but
she actually went on this tirade where
she was like I'm doing the worst and I
have threats so I will spend up to 200
000 if I have to and no one else has
ever had their life threatened besides
an elected official who could afford
private security so awesome with
campaign funds I'm glad she's defunding
the police isn't she part of the squad
isn't she one of these socialists
but here's the thing well I want to
educate her because I don't know if you
know this but I'm a socialist Tim are
you and yes I think that it's wrong that
the ultra wealthy should be the only
people with access to security I believe
we should universalize security by
having people's taxes find like security
guards but for the whole public so
you're saying Universal private security
Universal privacy a single-payer private
security system and I think some of
these these sock dams and socialists
might be interested in something like
that I like that I don't know it's a
hard sell you know they're they're
they're very much only the wealthy
should so only the wealthy should have
security Tim apparently that's their
plan oh no no no no Sheamus you
misunderstand their staunch Defenders of
the Second Amendment oh no that's right
yeah that's right of course now of
course I'm being a little bit silly here
private security is one of the things or
I shouldn't say private security but
security is one of the things that it's
reasonable for the state to provide so
we don't call that socialism but it's
funny to me how the government's
supposed to fund everything except for
the basic things that it actually is
supposed to fund like the police we got
this story we got a bunch of other
stories Israel is now moving to three
coveted shots three three yeah yeah
there's some there's some breaking news
I haven't I haven't been able to verify
yet there's a I don't speak Hebrew and
there's a report that came out from
Israel's Channel 13. I could not verify
the translation because I oh I've only
just seen it came out earlier today he
only just started Hebrew school but yeah
but I can tell you that there's a report
saying that the the infection rates are
going way way up in Israel
hospitalizations are way up and they're
contemplating another hard lockdown but
they're gonna try a third coveted shot
to see if that works and now Dr fauci
has said they are rushing for approval
for a third shot for those that are
immunocompromised or weakened so you
look based on that based on Joe Biden's
illegal eviction moratorium that he put
into place in the Supreme Court said you
can't do it yeah I think whether or not
there's going to be another lockdown the
rule of law was just smacked Supreme
Court's like you do not have the
authority to demand people give their
property to somebody else and Joe Biden
went I'm gonna do it anyway
was there like a property tax moratorium
uh are these these uh landlords who own
property no longer required to fulfill
their obligation to give the government
money or don't say landlord say retiree
say retiree yeah honestly the 60 year
olds who who put their their retirement
funds into like a two flat and rent out
a portion of it and that's their
retirement yeah those are the people
getting hit by this yeah well that's the
thing like landlord has become this
political cuss word but most landlords
are not uber wealthy people you know
they're in the middle of their middle
class or their retirees this is the way
they supplement their income or try to
make a living for them fixed income yeah
so we're going to talk about all that
obviously Sheamus is here he's talking
yes I am Sheamus Freedom Tunes I run
this channel called Freedom Tunes t-oons
youtube.com freedomsunes we're going to
be uploading a cartoon tomorrow about
Good Old Dr fauci as a matter of fact so
feel sure
droplets if you want to go over there
and check that subscribe and check that
out tomorrow this is the most martial of
laws I've ever experienced in the United
States 40 years or something I've never
seen it to the point where it's just
they just override the Supreme Court and
it's kind of weird and I know that like
they did during the Spanish Flu you know
like during times of disease has been a
notable time for governments to take
martial law action but I wasn't
expecting it it was different it was
different back when you had sort of a
consensus when you had culture and
community and everyone kind of agreed
right now you have the internet and all
this different conflicting data and it's
driving people crazy and making people
second-guess things it's really a weird
time well and also I don't know if I'm
gonna get in trouble for saying this but
this is not exactly the same as the
Spanish Flu in terms of deadliness
as far as we can tell yeah a lot of that
was sanitary well they didn't have a lot
of the Spanish the Spanish Flu is almost
the exact reverse because it caused your
immune system to turn on your body so
younger people with healthier immune
systems were more likely to die of it
and in this case covet I think it's
something like 80 of covet deaths are
people above the age of 65. so it's just
it's much more likely it's much more
likely to affect the elderly whereas the
Spanish Flu is much more likely to
affect younger healthier people I think
and And to clarify too I think the
booster shots in Israel are for people
over 60. interesting but uh we got Lydia
president I am here in the corner
pushing buns it is in fact my birthday
thank you guys for joining me on my
birthday it's a wonderful birthday happy
birthday everyone in my life so we hit a
pinata earlier yeah uh Sheamus freaking
destroyed that pinata
it was really really fun I appreciate
that cool I missed that ah yeah what'd
you hit it with a bat
all right ladies and gentlemen before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member to get access to
exclusive members only segment from the
Tim cast iron podcast as well as an
ad-free experience and you'll be
supporting our Fierce and independent
journalists that's right I'll slow down
a little bit that was good though that
was very clear yeah honestly I think I'm
gonna go do it like the Micro Machines I
should do those Radiohead
commercials.com become a member and you
will support our work um we got some two
new shows at the DND show we got the
mystery show and we're also launching a
non-profit to do fact checking I talked
about this like a year ago where we're
gonna sample take a random sampling of
Articles from a website from like three
from the past three months and then do a
journalistic ethics check and then give
them a score like X Out of 100. so it'll
be really interesting to see like New
York Times like a 60 out of 100 or
something and then like HuffPost will
get like a three out of 100. I'm not
even kidding because all their pieces
are opinion pieces and they don't label
them label them as opinion which means
they'll probably get a zero out of 100
no joke you gotta put opinion on an
opinion piece it's one of the standard
journalistic ethics so anyway go to
teamgifts.com sign up smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and let's
talk about what's happening with good
old Corey Bush my friends welcome to the
show
suck it up Corey Bush defends hiring
private security guards while demanding
America defund police this is brilliant
she said I'm going to make sure that I
have security because I know I man I
could just emphasize all the eyes I've
had attempts on my life or something and
I have to have too much work to do there
are too many people that need help right
now for me to allow that wow that is
someone who should just not be given any
more power in any other context for the
rest of their life like they have
already fallen into the perfect
totalitarian mindset I'm more important
than the average person so a different
set of rules should apply to me check it
out in her one sentence she says I'm
going to make sure that I have security
because I know I had attempts on my life
and I have too much too much work to do
there are too many people that need help
right now for me to a seven in one
sentence wow incredible that is really
fantastic yeah and I'm someone who says
I a lot as well but I'm impressed you
the Tim cast IRL it's in my name yeah
yeah she says so if I end up spending
two hundred thousand dollars if I spend
ten more dollars on it you know what I
get to be here to do the works yet and
so suck it up defunding the police has
to happen we need to defund the police
and put that money into social safety
nets okay to be fair said we in that
sentence she said we so that means she's
a woman of the people I'm convinced yeah
it comes out yeah this is I mean it's
the perfect example of moral licensing
right can can anybody question the squad
on their stance on guns that's a really
important thing because the left like
like real leftists they like they like
guns yes yeah yeah and so their support
base are progressives
what will the progressives think like
where are they at on this one I don't
think anyone's ever like okay Cortez how
do you feel about guns well here's the
thing I mean gun control is a losing
issue for the left so I wouldn't be
surprised if a lot of their base is very
much in favor of guns and would be
against the gun restrictions that the
more moderate Democrats tend to push for
I think it's establishment Democrats
that are anti-gun exactly leftists are
pro-gun like I think a good portion of
like Union Democrat Democrat like
working guys yeah if they still exist
yeah there are some no I know some yeah
and the days of uh ballistic fabrication
have evolved I mean you can you can 3D
print Weaponry Now That Couldn't didn't
exist 20 years ago the the whole idea of
legislating illegality to something that
people can do in their house
is insane I mean like you can make meth
in your house I mean I guess
that's possible I was like physically
but not legally yeah yeah no that's
that's my point I mean but then the drug
war has been a failure but clearly we
can legislate things you can make in
your house but I agree it makes it a lot
more difficult and it's going to be a
massive uphill battle for the people who
want to regulate guns not only be
because as you said you can make these
things in your house and the technology
is improving but because the vast
majority of the public isn't on board
with that agenda do you ever hear about
that guy who made a radio radiation
death ray in his garage and he like
irradiated his whole neighborhood and so
the government found out because they
were getting this crazy like really
intense reading and he had taken a bunch
of common like radioactive materials
because they exist all over the place
and he like made a big cluster of it and
then he put it in like I I could be I
could be getting the story wrong so
someone factored me because I just read
it on the internet somewhere but he
created like a lead casing with a hole
and then he put all of this radioactive
material in it and it focused the
radiation out of it and so apparently
they came and like shut him down he got
offered a job then kept doing illegal
stuff with radiation it was like covered
in lesions so they like oh my goodness
kicked him out of whatever it is they
were doing I was just thinking just real
quick I bring that up because of what
your point was like that self like home
fabrication of things it literally
happens but the the reason I brought up
2A in the first place in the context of
the squad is Corey Bush says defund the
police all right and many of the
leftists have said straight up abolished
the police now here's the problem I have
with their view on this is that
they want private security for
themselves yes they don't want you to
have guns and they want to take away
your police that is anarcho tyranny to
the most extreme degree my position has
abolished the police and give everyone
Guns by mandate I was just thinking like
if you if you established a global
Second Amendment
um like how often do civilians from one
country ever get charged with attacking
another country it's like in the last
400 years there was that guy in San
Francisco who shot that woman so like
but I mean like military like military
escapades in the last 400 years I can't
really pick like a citizen attack on
another country it's always the
government so if these citizens were
armed we would probably see a lot less
war
you know here's disarming the citizens
doesn't necessarily mean to get rid of
the military in that country right you'd
still have a military but you'd also
have an armed citizenry on both sides so
oh and I get what you're saying yeah you
know my my view of it is like uh so I've
I've been saying abolish the police just
because I see I see what's going on with
you know the Metro Police in DC and the
Capitol Police what happened with that
guy in his own home getting arrested
what happened in Seattle with the cops
actually defending antifa and I'm like
dude call their Bluff call them out say
just okay people should have right to
defend themselves and if you know if
cops aren't gonna aren't going to do it
right but my view is uh give everybody
guns right Second Amendment you have
right to keep their arms Okay then if
we're gonna have Universal Health Care
we're gonna have Universal guns as well
but I'll put it really really simply
I don't see people in their cars just
like randomly like crashing into houses
and like hit slamming the gas and
slamming into old ladies or anything
like how is it that people have access
to this very powerful machine that can
just hit somebody and they don't they
don't I I kind of think people don't
want to kill other people for the most
part yeah I mean look there are a lot of
traffic fatalities and you also have a
lot of accidental gun deaths but
generally speaking people aren't going
out and killing each other now before
2020 violent crime was on a downward
Trend so we could say something like
that and have data to back us up more
strongly but unfortunately because of
the summer of Rage as they call it crime
rates have more or less biked again and
we'll see how long they stay up for
whether they decline I'm sure they will
but who knows maybe things actually just
get worse and we can't make the case
that people will be peaceful with their
guns but they'll still need them to
protect them so this is my position on
cops right now I mean you look at what
happens with with uh Chauvin he gets
arrested and charged that that Kim woman
that Kim Potter and she gets arrested
and charged and I'm like if if
everything thing is going to be beholden
to the far left the last thing we need
is a police force to enforce the whims
of the far left sorry so you know when
Corey Bush comes out you're like we're
going to defund the police I'm like
better do it now before they take more
control in government and then start
using the cops against regular
working-class people
I don't know the um we got to clarify
like what does that mean to fund yeah
because I know when wash was on the show
a couple nights ago he immediately
thought the inarco version of it which
is completely remove the funding so so
abolish basically he also said it hadn't
happened and I was like there was a
report last year it was like 265
departments had like their budget
slashed by substantial numbers I think
New York slashed a billion right a
billion so that's that's a defunding not
an abolishment I mean look I believe Law
and Order is very important on the one
hand on the other hand I think there
maybe is something to allowing these
left-wing cities to engage in some
self-sabotage and see how that goes for
them and maybe that corrects some of the
bad thinking ultimately I would leave it
up more to local uh governments and
regions to determine what their police
force should look like and you know what
I'll clarify this too I didn't say
abolish the sheriffs or you know or
Troopers I'm talking about these big
cities where things are like run by
democrats and then the Democrats
complain about their own mistakes I'm
like okay I don't live there you know
when you have a baby or a child that's
like don't touch the hot stove kid and
then the kid's like uh and wants to do
it and you're like what are you going to
do eventually you got to let them live
his life if he touches the stove he
burns his finger and he realizes I
shouldn't do that again you can't spend
your whole life keeping the kid out of
the kitchen so in a way maybe we should
let these cities rip their police
departments apart I I think if that's
what they want if that's who they vote
for then either here's the way I see it
right like I mentioned first and
foremost I look at what happened when
there was like a bunch of right-wing
dudes in Portland or whatever and the
cops started beating him up yeah then
there that then they've got obviously
the the the capital police crying and
saying Trump's racist and all that stuff
and then you see the guy in Milwaukee
who gets arrested for after people were
at his house threatening his own house
yes now that that you know right right
under the surface it's like okay there's
clearly an issue there but the other
there's another two issues that I think
are important if the Democrats come out
and say they want to abolish or defund
their police I'm like first of all I
don't live there and I'm more
libertarian so I say well then they can
run their Community as they see fit
within reason
maybe they're right maybe they're right
huh it'll be a Utopia with no police
I highly doubt it well hey and maybe
they're wrong and then maybe regular
people in these cities will be like wow
we shouldn't vote for those people I
think a lot of those people will leave
though to be honest it's already
happening a lot of people are leaving
the cities the property values are
decreasing I mean Chicago has been
shrinking that's my point of reference
everyone's crossing the border over to
Indiana because they want to live
somewhere that sensibly run and they
want to vote for policies which are not
sensible so they can destroy the the way
they did the place they just came from
well to be honest there's a lot of
places in Indiana that have already been
destroyed that's fair that's very fair
yeah you go over to Gary and it's like
yeah yeah yeah for those that aren't
familiar Gary is like the armpit of
America Gary Gary I think Gary Illinois
Gary Indiana in Englewood in Chicago
like go back and forth for murder
capital oh wow so they're generally
Gary's like heavily industrialized isn't
it it's like the industrial Zone
apocalyptic it was a long time ago they
had a steel industry and then I left it
before the 80s I'd say last time I went
to Gary it was crazy because you'd go to
like a a block like a residential block
and every fourth house was a house and
in between it was just abandoned falling
apart chaos and it was really weird to
see like a regular house sitting right
there like a car and then like
everything destroyed next to it you walk
down the street and there's a school
Windows blown now the whole the craziest
thing man the school there's like
records of the the children who went
there in the 60s just everywhere you
could walk up pick up someone's file
find their name wow buildings like that
all over the place actually so what
happened was the police went in and just
started breaking windows and destroying
houses and it was all because it was
hunting people down that's right the
police were responsible and then they
defunded the police and now Gary doesn't
have many police and it's going great
that's an interesting phenomena in the
United States all these like Ghost Town
type these rubber boom again it's very
interesting I was born in Akron in Ohio
and it's a rubber Boone city after
Goodyear was formed there in the 50s and
40s and then uh when the rubber boom
stopped it became a ghost town but not
like Gary Gary had Akron didn't have
Chicago right next door so Gary's like
the beat up aftermath of a ghost town
yeah
I find it fascinating there's there's
all these different cities there's
another report that found Democrats in
all of these cities that had defunded
police were hiring massive private
security oh interesting this is what it
was like when I was growing up in
Chicago I remember my dad used to say
that these these politicians in Chicago
would always vote for more gun
restrictions and then have private
security guards with guns exactly they
can have guns yes I can have a gun to
protect myself I'll have a private
security Force to protect my family but
those stupid peasants out there let them
have five round magazines yep if they
can have a gun at all yeah what does she
think Corey Bush think is the point what
does she want to do defund the police
what does she mean like get like social
workers to go on calls of domestic abuse
and yes she said social what did she say
social safety nets does she understand
that like domestic abuse is some of the
most dangerous situations a human can
can walk into two enraged people in the
middle of a fight I don't know about two
enraged people often you get you'll get
like a dude abusing a woman it is true
that women abuse men as well but it's
disappointed fortunately men abusing
women right and that's why I'm like
ladies you need to have proper training
and Firearms man and all dude I heard
this I used to live next door to this
couple and I could hear them through the
walls and and they were they would fight
a lot and one night I heard the guy come
home and then I heard the girl like
I was like meh and she was like and the
guy was like meh and she she enraged the
guy and then the guy started beating her
and I called the cops but like she and
she instigated it it was crazy how
domestic abuse is like this six can can
be a six cycle that both people become
like used to well look you I can call
you a bunch of dirty names that doesn't
mean you should take no he was in the
wrong and call the cops on him right and
you're right you're right police show up
to that and that's some of the most
dangerous stuff they could encounter
here's a guy who's attacking somebody
you don't know what's going on and
sometimes the guy's innocent even
there's like a lot of these stories are
kind of scary too I think it's
disproportionate but there are stories
where it's like the woman calls the cops
and the guy and the guy didn't do
anything and the cops come and arrest
the guy
it's tough job man I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna there's no two words about it and
what do you do do we just say like both
the men in the wind should be armed and
then when the fight breaks out they
shoot each other no obviously not that's
why when I talk about the police I think
the police are important I think they do
a hard job I think they do uh a mostly
good job and I think it's it's it's a a
fairly thankless in a lot of ways
because people don't like getting
tickets they don't like getting tickets
they don't got they don't like being
told no and then they get pulled over
and they're like you singled me out and
they're all angry and it's like well you
know man don't you know speed or
whatever the issue right now is just
it's it's way too hot politically and
the cultural institutions being
controlled by leftist ideologues I'm
like I'll tell you what's gonna happen
man because we've already seen it and
I've already said it 50 million times
they're gonna you know they're gonna
show up to your house or take away your
guns they're going to serve you a red
flag warrant they're going to arrest you
for defending yourself and they're gonna
let the extremists Smash Up windows and
do whatever they want so I'm like I like
sheriffs to do a good job there's some
bad stories about sheriffs but if these
big cities don't want their cops I'm
gonna have advocate for that my feeling
is it's going to be either socialized
police like what we kind of have now
federalized police or private police
that it will be one of those three if
not a mixture of all three which we kind
of have now so I'm afraid that if we
defund police socialized police that
we're going to have an influx of either
federal or private yep and that's that's
terrifying I'd rather have local
yes well that's what AOC said when asked
like what what would you be looking for
and she said we wanted to be more like
the suburbs
well that's a good point let's bring it
back to the days of Officer friendly
right how does she mean by that I guess
she's saying that like in the suburbs
the cop will pull you over and be like
how's it going there Ian good day you
are speeding again and then you're gonna
be like I'm sorry officer Smith mag well
you slow down there son and then he and
then he leaves and he wants like my dad
was a fireman they knew my dad you know
your cross one's kid white proof get out
of here White Privilege here's a warning
one time I got a warning yeah that was
what was fireman privilege fireman I'm
not kidding city worker privilege check
out I wanna I wanna pull up this uh we
got this
that our guys wrote this for timcast.com
that's a great picture liberal Utopia
San Francisco woman seen holding AK-47
from passenger window of speeding car
it's amazing uh there there's the photo
it's a lady hanging out the window I
guess she got arrested
um my understanding is it's not an AK-47
someone mentioned it's a uh it was an
akm 74 something like that I don't know
for sure
but she has terrible trigger terrible
Trigger Discipline she's ready man yeah
so but this brings up an interesting
issue I was thinking about uh you know
Universal guns and stuff like that
if you're driving your car erratically
like I think the cop can pull you over
and say get out of the car like you're
driving a radical like if you're driving
drunk if you're brandishing a weapon
outside of a vehicle like I don't think
it's a violation of your second
amendment if a cop's like I'm taking
that away from you more importantly with
her finger on the trigger yeah yeah
should you bust people just for that you
think if someone's walking around
carrying and then they have their bad
Trigger Discipline like she's holding
the gun it looks like I I don't I don't
I don't think she was intending on
shooting anybody I'm not sure but she's
holding it like low ready basically with
her finger on the trigger yeah I think
she should have that taken away and you
know she's the passenger yeah yeah she
is hanging hanging out of the window but
this is San Francisco dude things are
going well over there so I was I was
really curious though um and I don't
know if we read this in the article but
was this part of like a gang war or
something no I think she was just
driving kind of doing it it was a speed
event with a gun yeah it was funny
because a lot of comments were like man
she's so dumb but that photo is awesome
that's a pretty uh killer photo wow wow
it's not awesome dude I I look at this I
gotta be honest this lady out of a car
holding that gun and I'm not somebody
who's got extensive training I'm like
it's embarrassing you know what I mean
like if I took a photo so we we did a
photo shoot for uh when we we had forced
here for recoil mag oh yeah and I'm like
very careful make sure you're telling me
how to stand and like how to hold it
because the last thing I want is to have
a photo of me holding it wrong yeah like
she's going to be all over the Internet
and I don't know if she cares though
she's not like it seems like since the
movies movies have been invented that
people have become desensitized to like
the horrors of of danger in a lot of
ways and and like because 150 years ago
if that had come out that someone was
driving around like a psycho screaming
with their finger on the trigger of a
weapon that would be a huge deal for
that City they'd have to do something
about that person but now it's like it's
a hero it's an action hero or the Dylan
where the John Dillinger days I almost
didn't say that because there were like
what are they Bonnie and Clyde and like
their old like villains that were kind
of looked at like Heroes yeah
anti-heroes or I don't know yeah it's
kind of weird isn't it yeah like John
Dillinger you know people look back on
him with some kind of reverence it's
been like a mad distrust for the state
and like a love of local Authority yeah
well now San Francisco is just devolving
I mean could this be you know what's
really funny as we're sitting here
laughing like haha she's so dumb in San
Francisco what's so dumb could this be
like the beginning of the Wild West days
of America like where it's like the
dystopian era is beginning the the
eviction moratorium is totally illegal
Biden's just basically blatantly
disregarding all law and precedence in
this country in rather Extreme Ways to
be fair Obama and Trump did Kill
American citizens I think Obama's was a
bit more egregious trumps was a bit
Reckless
we've had bad orders from presidents for
a long time but now it's like
here at home you know what I mean like
when Obama killed I've got this this mic
armor when when Obama killed those
Americans with a drone strike you know
nobody knew it happened and they didn't
care yeah and Trump had ordered a
Commando raid which ended up We Believe
killing a little girl so actually I
should say that the the Trump thing is
not confirmed though we believe it was
the case
um people don't see that stuff now
you've got Joe Biden being like I'm
going to the Supreme Court to see if I
can do this thing and the Supreme
Court's like you can't do this thing and
then he's like Congress can you do this
thing and they're like we can't do this
thing and he goes and I'll do it anyway
the craziest thing is that Joe Biden
threatened to arrest people for evicting
somebody a year in jail under what
Authority could he do none literally
none literally Supreme Court's like you
can't do it he goes okay I'll do it
anyway Supreme Court can't do anything
to stop it so when you see that and you
see poop all over the streets I tell you
this man this woman riding around with
their gun
what did you think was going to happen
when people know they can break the law
with impunity in San Francisco they walk
that guy walks into Walgreens right I
don't know I'm sorry he rides his bike
into Walgreens and then he has a garbage
bag and he fills it up with stuff and
then he rides out and the security guard
doesn't do anything and Chester Bowden
actually defended the guy
who's just the D.A he said something
like
oh he was desperate you know and then
and he told this story a year ago about
how we have to make sure that we don't
we don't make unintended consequences
happen by arresting these dealers and
they told a story about how one dealer
was uh was trafficked here and had to
sell drugs to pay off the dealers who
were holding his dad hostage and I'm
like so you're saying this guy comes
here and he's selling drugs on our
streets and we have to tolerate it
because his dad's in danger like that
makes literally no sense I'm sorry like
I don't want anything bad to happen to
his dad but how is it that we're gonna
let him deal drugs pay off the
kidnappers and rescue his dad what are
you talking about yeah it's bad to stop
that's San Francisco this is what you
get when you get District Attorneys much
like Corey Bush who are like these
Progressive Democrats who are just like
tear it all down
yeah I'm thinking about like ancient
history and basically that the
totalitarian of human history if if
someone were to go under like a farmer's
land and take three of their goats and
then get caught and the farmer's like
why'd you take my goats and they're like
I had to Feed My Starving family they
would hang that guy
not even a trial they just take them and
and like put them to death basically for
thievery uh and we've gone now we're in
such an abundant society that it's like
thievery isn't isn't such a big deal
maybe it seems like well I feel like
we're able to see a lot more of like the
the extra downsides of theft and robbery
because I was learning the other day
they are two totally different things um
we can now see what robbery does to for
example businesses that work in a
neighborhood and we can see everything
it does to the it like disheartens the
people that live there and it makes them
want to leave like this lady riding
around like it's freaking Grand Theft
Auto that's Insanity I feel like all we
need is a drought for San Francisco to
look like literal Madness in a drought
what do you mean well there you go this
is Mad Max it's starting in California
California's in a dragon right oh my God
the drought is so bad that they're
stopping people from pulling water out
of the Delta oh my gosh bro I gotta be
honest I'm looking at what's going on
with the with the eviction moratorium
the debt ceiling crisis those are very
very big unemployment just being cranked
out till September now you're seeing
stuff like this you're seeing more of
the defund the police stuff and I'm like
it is Mad Max like it is it is a
controlled collapse almost it feels like
I mean I I want you to picture this in
your heads everybody there's a giant
skyscraper and there is a giant
voltron-like Japanese robot punching
buildings and the building is gets
knocked over and Joe Biden who's 70 feet
tall grabs it he's got hairy legs and
he's got hair very hair very hairy legs
and he's holding up the building as it's
collapsing and he's going come on
it's not a good movie it's the end of
the second seconds you know you know in
like sequels that that are part of
trilogies it's always a cliffhanger yeah
that's it the Cliffhanger is Joe Biden
can't lift the building back up and he's
like come on and it goes down and then
the sequel is it just crushes him it's
terrible so everything what I mean is it
feels like the system is falling over
and they're trying to hold it doesn't
just feel like it's him yeah he's saying
it yeah yeah when you get San Francisco
with like people hanging out windows
like speeding and ladies holding a gun
I'm like well let's not be frogs what do
you think was gonna happen what's the
difference between thievery and robbery
uh I guess that thievery doesn't require
any kind of holding somebody up you just
sneak in and take stuff whereas robbery
requires somebody like cause threaten
some kind of thing oh physical harm
Robert give me your stuff and that's
still somebody hugs you so San Francisco
robbery is still legal but they're
allowing Petty thievery yeah well um
everything under 950 the police
basically don't respond to because
they're misdemeanors or something like
that and so people can walk what about
what about 200 000 private security
forces do you think they'll respond if
something worth 950 bro let me tell you
let me let me tell you about private
security Private Security will punch a
punch a cop in the face if their client
wants them to or needs them too no no
joke they have like yeah right we've had
people comment and Super Chat talking
about this but it's true private
security they do not care if they have a
client it depends it depends well they
don't have to play politics either if
you're hiring a 15 an hour private
security guard for an event he's gonna
be like I don't care he probably doesn't
need a gun like for Corey bush she's
hired seventy thousand dollars in
private security and she's a politician
these are the kind of people they're
gonna tell the cop to screw off and the
cops gonna try and walk through and
they're gonna block him and be like
we're not gonna you're not getting past
us it's not gonna happen there now for
Millionaires and billionaires those are
the kind of guys who are like literally
would punch a cop in the face but
security guards will do whatever they
want yeah and they'll like fly the guy
out of the country
yeah they'll get him on a yacht and
they'll take them out him and his family
get him to the get him uh 12 miles out
to sea or whatever get Abu Dhabi yep set
you up in a really nice hotel nice Suite
you know until a police officer does
that for me to fund them defund all the
cops because they don't provide us with
that because they won't take no to
international waters what if we get like
uh a police and it was like subscription
service so you get like police police
plus and police goals that's where it is
that's where we're headed to I mean if
everything becomes private security what
other option do we have people are just
going to start ironing private security
and local communities they'll band
together and go well the police have
been defunded we need some way to
protect ourselves the Millionaires and
billionaires have private security so
why don't we pull together as a
neighborhood and hire our own private
security force and then they do and then
we end up in and capistan which is crazy
to me that the left have become the
proponents of them
imagining like check it out like you you
someone breaks in your house and like
they run off you call the police and
like you're a regular working-class
person and the cop shows up and he's
like I see you're using our uh our our
our our basic package uh for Police
Service so uh the person's not you're
getting five bullets
as the the perpetrator is no longer here
I think you're safe and we have
fulfilled our requirements under the
basic plan have a nice day good sir feel
free to come contact us if you'd ever
like to upgrade then you get someone
who's got like Platinum Platinum Plus
and the cop shows up and they show up
with a fruit baskets
for your dog but you get the premium
version they like put him down ethically
with like a nice injection but either
way your dog is going to die well you
did call us it is
you could see like a basic package where
they'll they'll they'll apprehend the
guy and then let him go but then there's
like the gold package where they operate
them and they'll actually take them to
the courthouse and do the paperwork for
you for the Platinum Platinum Plus if
you're like a millionaire and you spend
like 20 grand a month on the police
they bring them into the basement where
there's chains over a pipe and they're
like here you go sir is part of the
Platinum Platinum Plus uh VMA for you
yeah we got a piece of his hair yeah
he's now going to live in your basement
I I heard the private security agents
cost it's the insurance uh to hire those
guys because like each person's like a
million dollars in insurance to cover so
you can't the normal person just cannot
afford that stuff so I'm saying you
pulled together and if people started to
come together because like technically
if you get a legal weapon you are your
own private security Force but as soon
as you start to to build a force I think
that you become then liable for
insurance I I
really do think though I think if we did
abolish the police it would basically be
the end of the U.S
yeah because because it's like you were
saying what would happen is people would
either form local militias or local
security companies would come in now
imagine this you live and let's call it
like uh let's call it uh Hills side
which I'm sorry somebody watching lives
in Hillside let's say there's a hillside
neighborhood and the police are all
disbanded and fall apart and so they say
we definitely need a security Force you
know police for our local community so
they create one and they all put they
all pitch in money and now they have
their local Hillside police well next
next to Hillside is valleyside and they
do the same thing and then one day a kid
from Hillside gets into a fight with the
kid and valleyside punches them the kid
goes on hits aside on the curb and dies
yeah the kill side kid runs away after
the kid dies and then the valley side
police are like we're gonna go get him
because he you know he came in here then
the hillside police are like you can't
come in here and then you have feuding
neighborhoods as if they are like micro
Nations if you get rid of the police I'm
not uh I I'm not going to agree with the
end caps on this one that's why I said
when I talk about a box of place it's
not for the same reason as a lot of ant
caps in libertarian and so they have
been calling me based for saying it no I
think what would really happen is you'd
have a conflict from Regional
departments and then what One Police
Department's like we got to go to um
here's a better example kid from
Hillside goes to valleyside and steals a
five thousand dollar you know uh item
and fillets with it and then the
hillside cops are like you're not coming
in our neighborhood we don't know we
don't care and we're not investigating
that for whatever reason the valleyside
cops are like we're getting our property
back for our patrons and then what then
they go in there and they shoot
everyone's dog gang war yeah they go in
there everyone wakes up and all the dogs
are dead the dogs are dead they like
sneak they come in their house Mission
Impossible from the ceiling like just to
take the dog out the targeted hit that's
assuming too that these neighborhoods
have the same laws because then you'd
start to get even more Grand your little
local level law like it's okay to steal
up to two thousand dollars in Hillside
but in Valley side it's a it's a crime
yeah
look at San Francisco when they said
they're not they're not going to
prosecute these crimes people from all
over the area are going there to steal
they're like hey freebie it's what
happened in Ferguson the people who were
rioting in Ferguson did not live there
they were smashing windows and stealing
stuff and it's got to be bleeding over
from San Francisco into the surrounding
neighborhoods and and cities
Barbara Boxer oh yeah Democrat senator
from California got mugged by a child
okay a kid we'll call say kid because
it's a young teenager like an 18 17 year
old no no no like 15. is it 14 or 15
like six foot 180 pounds I don't know
about that but apparently he like pushed
her grabbed her phone she I think she I
don't know if she fell over but then he
jumped in a car and she was like why
would you do that to a grandma and I'm
just like you know there are bad people
you need to be protected from let me
tell you this man that's crazy you ever
see have you seen that that Purge
episode of Rick and Morty yes you're not
the rich people think they're safe in
The Purge they will make a world they
will truly regard
what I mean is these Elite political
class individuals these democrats for
the most part I want to defund and get
rid of all these cops I am of the firm
belief that when they do that they will
absolutely regret it well 100 when
people say things like why would
somebody do something like this okay
there are so many reasons but did you
really think they wouldn't did you not
understand that there were people out
there that do those kinds of things and
like will hurt people and she defunded
the police for him though so that he
didn't get he should have known he
didn't get profile well but hold on was
there like a social worker nearby when
this happened to ask him about his
feelings before he mugged her yeah
because then it probably wouldn't have
happened so so Scott Adams has this
theory that Democrats really don't
understand human motivation and I'm
inclined to agree because Democrats
seemed inclined to believe that people
aren't going to do bad things to other
people
and if anything bad happens to for
example a minority or person that
Community it's because someone else is
doing a terrible thing so it's like
either you believe that everyone's
basically good or you think that
everyone's basically bad except
minorities I think I generally agree but
my thing with Scott Adams is I just
don't take political advice from
cartoonists that's fair
no no but it's making fun of himself
yeah yeah because yes but uh but yeah I
am a cartoonist but no I think that's
true they don't understand human
motivation and if you go to many of the
thinkers that were held up by the
laughter influence the left historically
like Rousseau who think that humans are
fundamentally good
um you you get into this place where the
only way someone could possibly do
something bad is if they were engineered
by a society to commit the wrongdoing
guys
I got bad news
what's that Spiffy's is closed I don't
even know what it is that's just news
this is this is direct evidence the
collapse is here the country has fallen
you know what else is messed up the
dairy so there's this Dairy Queen in
Indiana I used to go to and they don't
have Dilly Bars there anymore wow
check out the story uh from timcast.com
Diner closed closes fine uh Diner closes
find 400 000 for violating covid-19
rules uh chlo wait what Diner closes I
think they got a typo in the headline
copy editor guys what are you doing
timcast.com uh a diner that was fined
400 000 for violin and covet has closed
permanently the Washington Eatery was
once referred to as the flash point for
covid Rebellion by local news outlets
they uh Unfortunately they shut down
they said it was due to Staffing
shortages and food delivery problems not
the fines so it wasn't the fines
interesting okay but uh I'm sure the
fines had to contribute something to it
or they were just ignoring them yeah
well okay fair enough but uh I I
jokingly say oh spiffy is close it's a
50 year old Diner wow in DC it sucks 50
years so so look this is just one
example of all the businesses that we've
seen destroyed because of what's been
going on in the economy and it's
fascinating if you look at Civics
they're uh they're they're polling
Democrats right now actually think the
economy is good talk what wait how could
you genuinely think the economy is good
right now
I'm confused yeah that's unbelievable
this article no no here we are not
understanding uh motivation yeah there
you go yeah how could you think this
economy is good it seems like a human
let me see if I can uh pull this up and
uh I don't I don't think it's fair to
say necessarily that they're like saying
it's the best right now 36 percent of
people in general think that the economy
is fairly good huh but hold on hold on
let's do it by Democrat only
58 of Democrats think the economy is
doing good right now
twenty percent say fairly bad nine
percent unsure seven seven percent say
very good well but that because this is
that's the kind of economy that they
want businesses are shutting down people
aren't able to provide services to the
public they're not able to keep their
door opens but a bunch of people who
aren't working or getting money from the
government with them that's a good hold
on hold on I I no I think I have an
answer to this if you switch to
Republican 40 say very bad 38 say fairly
bad and 17 say fairly good among
independent voters
33 percent say fairly bad 29 say very
bad and 29 say fairly good I'll tell you
what this is It's people who watch CNN
yeah yeah you're a Democrat and you're
sitting there watching CNN withdrawal
pouring out of your mouth like and
they're like everything is great the
economy is recovered in your life it's
Insanity since Insanity meanwhile
Republicans are like my 401k is not
doing so well I'm buying gas I'm out of
work right now like I might be out of
work and other people I know might be
out of work but the economy's doing well
because the media told me it is and you
know we're getting checks from the
government right now and that can last
forever and we're going to keep being
locked down because varying after Varian
is going to pop up and they're never
going to let us go back to our jobs
until we get this 7th and 8th and Ninth
dose of the vaccine but no yeah things
are great the economy is doing fine it's
not a rebound a direct I think rebound
the result of the way that the public
school teaches kids zero about economics
I mean I learned about money dimes and
nickels in first grade and I bet I think
that was the last they were talking
about economics until College I had to
take an economics we had banking in my
school we had like minor stuff but I
didn't understand like um compound
interest I didn't understand the way
that works that's if you look at the
numbers and you know compound interest
you can see that it's not good we we had
we had uh in second grade they opened up
bank accounts for kids that's awesome oh
awesome we also had we also had mock uh
presidential elections like great but I
think that might have been a polling
thing like to see what the kids would
say and so like I was I remember being a
little kid and they had like one of
those old um dot matrix computers and
then everyone on the line and they were
like pick who you want to be president I
was like rasparent
I guess I vaguely remember this I'm
probably getting it wrong because I was
probably like I don't know how old I was
six or something he's seven and it
because it what they're trying to do is
to see what what kids would say and it
showed what their parents were thinking
and so you know my parents I think voted
for Bill Clinton but for some reason I
was like yeah I tried to get my dad to
vote for Russia I was like any vote for
Clinton I don't know vote for pro I
couldn't get those ears but um the
economy's on fire yes and uh
we're watching this this controlled
collapse of everything so you so we were
just talking about this previously but
you combined this with abolition of
police defunding of police you combine
this with Joe Biden Define the Supreme
Court and just threatening people with
jail for not uh uh uh you know well this
is a consequence of having a system
where the people who make all of the
decisions will still have firearms from
their private security when they ban
your guns we'll still have private
security when they defund the police
we'll still be getting their paychecks
from their corporate donors when they
shut the economy down and your business
gets destroyed they face absolutely no
consequences for making decisions that
ruin life for the average American I
think we are in a simulation oh why is
that because they're just like whoever
is running it they're like uh increase
the difficulty are they reacting no
increase the difficulty again uh did
they did they start reacting no okay
drink it up to 12. how many 12 oh geez
they're still not doing anything like it
feels like they're just slowly turning
up the knob on the pressure and people
are just like okay with it like no turn
the difficulty up but tell them the
economy is doing really good and see how
many of them actually believe that well
that's part of the difficulty I mean
it's like propaganda telling everything
everyone's fine but they're saying
things like staff shortages food
shortages gas shortages and it's it's
it's it's becoming impossible to to to
run your business dude what a bungling
of this to give people unemployment that
they will lose if they take their job
back in a lot of countries they would
just companies that had to let people go
for kova the government would pay the
people that they'd let go because they
were still working there and then when
they were able to go back they would
just go back to the job they keep
getting paid now by the job again
they're creating an addiction to
government yeah if they go back to work
they lose their government paycheck and
their government insurance you know it's
unemployment insurance which gets taxed
on for some reason your insurance
payment you're getting an equivalent of
16 bucks an hour not to work and you're
looking at all these jobs and you're
like but even if I take it I lose this
dude gonna ride this out those people
have to pay taxes on that unemployment
and I don't know if they're even
planning for that I mean how can you
when you're living paycheck to paycheck
you know I find remarkable is that we
had vosh on the show just you know uh
two days ago he was in favor he was like
I'm in favor of Ubi and I'm like have
you not read the news concern you're
like you know with respect you know I'm
glad you came on had a good conversation
but I disagree with him like have you
not read the news or watched what's
going on with because we're giving this
people money and you you hear this
propaganda the anti-work on Reddit it's
like one of the you know what's funny is
like reddit's got a lot of lazy people I
tell you this I've not read it they're
like we shouldn't have to work it's like
okay invent replicators and I got no
problem with that like you can sit
around and just say the tea Earl Gray
hot and then you're not going to work
but everything else requires work
because of I don't know the second law
of Thermodynamics but anyway we're in
Ubi
this is it I I said this I remember I
was I was hanging out when I was on Joe
Rogan he asked me like what do you think
about Ubi and I I was like I think
people wouldn't want to work and then
you get these leftists saying like oh
that's not true
actually you know you know my favorite
question is like uh Ian I mean no no I'm
sorry Sheamus yes
[Laughter]
to answer this one how many what how
many people do you know play the guitar
play the guitar oh man that's a good
question I went to an art school Tim so
you're looking at a disproportionate
sample here just so probably like let's
say I know five people who play guitar
and how many of them are bad at Guitar
oh man I don't know I don't ask my
friends to play for me I'm just like I'm
sure you're great like I just don't even
know how many how many you think I think
here's the thing the only people I know
who play guitar are people I know who
play because like I've been to their
shows and stuff so they're decent
they're good
um but I'm sure most funny people who
are bad at Guitar most people know what
like everybody plays some kind of
instrument to some degree not everybody
but like a lot of people and so most
most people will be like oh I know a few
people who play the guitar and honor
your bad I know a few of them are pretty
bad do you think the people who are bad
would stop working and try to become
famous musicians oh I could see it
happening yeah
especially when they're younger yeah I I
grew up in Chicago I knew tons of people
who had well-off Parents yeah who are
like I'm gonna make music and I'm like
bro you're not good at this like you
just you're not gonna be a celebrity
doing this and that's the thing about
Ubi you give someone money and to not
produce so here's what basically what it
basically means you're giving someone
money which is access to extract from
the system yes and then instead of
putting anything meaningful back in they
make bad music yeah exactly well so this
is interesting because it you can take
it a step further a lot of people want
to have you know YouTube channel or
twitch Channel they want to find some
way to make money with social media and
when you're starting you can hit a point
where you know maybe you're able to make
a couple hundred dollars a month that
doesn't necessarily mean you're cut out
for the industry that doesn't mean this
is going to be something that will turn
into a full-time career but that Ubi
plus a couple hundred dollars a month
from whatever you're doing on social
media could push you over the edge and
actually be enough for you to live off
of so it gives you an unrealistic idea
of what your prospects are and social
media is one example but there are all
sort of Arenas where you might be able
to make a little bit of money in that
combined with the stipend you're getting
from the government could be enough to
live off of but that's not where your
labor is most productively used by the
majority of people giving to and
receiving from from the economy so
you're actually doing a net disservice
to the country to the economy overall
exactly right so so I my view of this is
like okay here's here's an option easy
access to Grants for young people you
turn 18 you can now go to the local
Grant Center which is very easy to go to
you know present your little pamphlet be
like here's what I want to do and then
request a certain amount of money to
engage in that project because one of
the issues that I hear a lot from the
Ubi crowd is think about all the
talented people who are stuck working a
crappy job because if they quit they
lose their apartment they'd be homeless
and I'm like that's true there are a lot
of young people of great talent I know I
know growing up people who are insanely
good at skateboarding and I was like man
these guys got to go pro sorry they
didn't have the sponsors they didn't
have the means to film and they had to
work otherwise they'd lose their job and
out or they'd lose their apartment and I
was like if this guy was just given a
little bit of money so he could skate
we'd have great another great Pro so how
about instead of the worst of Both
Worlds we do The Best of Both Worlds you
gotta worry work to pay your bills and
at a certain age you can say like here's
what here's my plan I'm a young person
and then get a grant and that's it
that's your chance it's complicated
though because you have to ask the
question even if there are many talented
people in a particular field who don't
have an opportunity to try to enter it
you have to ask how many people with
that particular Talent can the economy
support so let's say everyone who's good
at skateboarding is able to get this
grant where they can become a
professional skateboarder I mean
realistically how many professional
skateboarders can our economy support
you know I don't think we're not we're
not offering them we're not offering an
infinite or indefinite amount of money
it's here's a grant to run your business
and they have to have a plan they come
to you with a plan saying I would like a
grant for this particular project for
sure I thought so it sounded to me like
the point that you were making was we'll
tap into all sorts of talent we haven't
gotten before but my concern is we'll
give a lot of money to people and
they'll end up with a lot of debt and
they're not really going to end up
control they end up in debt well because
they don't end up successfully taking oh
a grant I'm sorry okay yeah and I'm not
talking about 100 Grand I'm talking
about a few thousand dollars yeah yeah
so it's like they can invest some money
into something basically saying like can
we invest in young people instead of
indebting young people and putting them
in colleges that just grind them to the
to the to dirt yeah well one of the
weird things is I'm not entirely sure
how I feel about a grant but it is very
strange that almost you know any young
person can go get a loan to go off to
college even if the degree isn't going
to pay off for them and it's obvious
based on the degree they're choosing but
if you go in with a really solid
business plan at 18 the likelihood that
you're going to get a loan is extremely
low that's insane
that's totally backwards yeah I would
agree right right right but but and so
part of the reason that we have the
tuition crisis that we have in the
student debt crisis is because this is
not just my personal opinion I think
this is something that's borne out by
all the most basic rules of economics
and if you need a citation the National
Bureau for economic research has said
this is the case but colleges respond to
an increase in the availability of
student loans by increasing tuition
costs I mean so now we have absurdly
expensive college costs because the
government came in and said hey let's
help people go to college well it turns
out all they did was make it more
difficult for people to go and I don't
know if it was necessarily a plan in
their part I don't think it was I just
think they screw up whenever they try to
help and then you I mean college is
basically indentured servitude it's you
here's the money for your opportunity
and then you got to pay it back and then
most people can't and they get mad and
they demand communism and then I gotta
pay the bill for it well this thing well
I think what's even more Insidious is
many of them can pay it back I think
even a majority but the problem is the
people who can pay it back I mean look
there is an economic hierarchy in terms
of who is able to be accepted into
college in the first place so if you go
up in a rough neighborhood where you
weren't able to get the kind of
education that someone who went to a
decent private school or a good public a
decent public school as far as public
schools go and the suburbs uh went to
you're going to be less likely to get
into school right so when we forgive
student debt oftentimes what it does is
it redistributes wealth from working
people who never had the opportunity to
go to college and towards people who
started out in the upper class and then
went to college who are no longer being
expected to pay off the debts which they
voluntarily encourage so this is what I
actually responded to a leftist with
this and I I was on Twitter I thought I
was going to get just like all these
leftists screaming at me because they're
like somebody said something like that
they said uh it was a tweet about you
know when you say we shouldn't pay back
someone's you know forgive student debt
because you had to pay it off you're
basically saying they should suffer
because you didn't no and my response
was I just don't think it's right to
make working-class people pay off the
exactly of the highest income earn in
the country exactly not and people
actually like that's a good point yeah
college degree people with college
degrees earn higher salaries on average
than people without them why should
Working Class People pay off the debts
of the highest income earners we are
funneling money to the top tier no way
dude do the inverse how about we make
the college students with their High
incomes pay pay their fair share pay
your fair share well I mean often those
people end up going into the one percent
and paying an absorbent amount in taxes
but the one percent is not it's still
yeah or top ten percent well again I
mean the higher how about income earners
how about these people who took out
student loans pay their fair share yes
they got free money yeah and now they
want working poor people the proletariat
to pay their bills so it's actually true
pay your fair share college debt holders
should Define that that's basically true
Bernie Sanders
fair share is fair fair share is and to
be fair I'm not talking about exorbitant
interest rates yeah I think that's crazy
they're not interested it's unfair yes I
agree we're not about because my stance
has always been we can we can stop the
interest rates and say pay back your
remaining principal that's your fair
share but when they what they're saying
right now is Joe Biden could snap his
fingers and erase all federal debt for
for college students why doesn't he do
it because that would be you not paying
your fair share deluding the economy and
it would be an invisible tax on the
working class so you got free money you
have to spend it you pay your fair share
now hold on I agree with you the the end
the the the interest rates are insane
wrong and broken 100 that we get rid of
yeah yeah no I mean it's insane that you
could charge interest on a loan that's
guaranteed I understand some small
amount to hedge against inflation with
the idea right people one percent over
the lifetime or something or you know
you know something adequate to um
something adequate to offset the value
that will be lost through inflation but
not so much that you're able to profit
off the idea of like profiting off of a
gear or even just like uh if if you take
out 10 grand you owe an extra hundred
dollars like look if we're trying to uh
invest in young young people
to be better able and better capable
then I think we can give out straight
loans with you know with inflationary
interest but at a certain point you
should be able to pay back just to the
principal the the interest rates are
insane they compound a guitar I hear too
many stories from people who are like I
took out forty thousand dollars now I
own it now I owe 80 and it's like that's
that's completely insane that's
completely insane it shouldn't it
shouldn't I think if you like you're out
of work it should just stop like I don't
know man the system's broken and I'll
tell you this before we even get in any
of that stuff I'm like we need to re I'm
totally you know what I'll tell you this
here's my compromise I I will personally
accept a greater amount of of debt to be
erased outside of interest if it also
means we either seize the endowments on
the universities or and I I mean that
half jokingly or we we outright end the
the college loan debt pipeline that
whole thing has to stop well I mean no
they absolutely have to stop federally
guaranteeing student loans that's the
only way it comes back well let me
actually be clear there's going to be a
bubble at some point right at some I
mean bubble's gonna pop at some point I
should say we're already in a bubble
this can't sustain itself forever but
it's just clear that eventually they're
gonna have to stop federally subsidizing
these loans and certainly making the
problem worse that they do subsidize
them so they have to stop let's kind of
Pop either way though let's let's let's
Circle back sure Circle back okay we're
gonna Circle back to uh the covid
lockdowns in this business and the
economy because we have this story that
I find particularly interesting now in
the previous segment we're talking about
a business that accrued 400 000 fines
over violating these covert restrictions
now with the with the vaccine mandates
that that are popping up well for the
most with private businesses and now in
New York from a public uh uh from a
public place we had the story from
timcast.com Boston's Democrat mayor
Compares vaccine passports to papers
required during slavery and Jim Crow
interesting that's bold
the Democrat Boston mayor Kim Janey has
compared vaccine passports to the papers
required slavery and Jim Crow the first
black person to serve as mayor of the
city also compared vaccine passports to
demands that former president Obama show
his birth certificate during the
birtherism Scandal I mean this is this
is uh I agree I'm I'm I I'm not gonna uh
pretend to know about you know these
these horrible horrible things about
throughout history but what I say I
agree is that it is an overbearing
demand from the state on regular people
to implement these things to the extent
that you can't go to a store you can't
go to a bar you can't go to a music
venue or something now in New York I
don't think they're saying I think you
can go to stores still
they're saying indoor activities but as
far as I'm concerned if you mandate a
vaccine for one thing let's say they
were like you need a vaccine to go to
the hot dog stand on 7th Street about
that you've mandated vaccines it's over
as far as I'm concerned because you've
you've you've hit at a core function for
many people I don't care who or how many
so when they say if you want to go out
to eat you need it you need to have your
vaccinated vaccine card New York is
mandated vaccines period there's no
other reason to argue about it that's
wrong we saw that with The Offspring
drummer Pete I think Pete Prada's name
he's got uh Gian bar syndrome
and so he couldn't get it he couldn't
get the vaccine and now he's kicked out
of the band is that what we're going to
create we're going to create this
medical medical segregation is he
actually kicked out of the band Yes
that's Insanity it yeah what he went to
the doctor he has he had a young age he
developed uh guillain-bar syndrome which
is it's an extremely rare side effect
for people when they get some vaccines
and there's it emerges for other reasons
too but it can be a side effect it is a
side effect of the Johnson Johnson
vaccine and there are many doctors who
advise against hitting the vaccine if
you have this syndrome which he did
out of the band you're gone sanity isn't
that a VI like don't we have violations
of like the Americans with Disabilities
Act can we be like if you're
experiencing this and is limiting to you
like we we we we protect you in that
regard well I think at this point it
becomes very clear that it's all about
having you bend the knee if anyone was
unaware
um if a person is disabled and has a
very good medical reason for not getting
vaccinated and your response is to kick
them out because they haven't taken your
preferred route for handling this
situation it's obvious that what you're
interested in is submission let me pull
up the story we have from The Daily Mail
more than half of unvaccinated Americans
believe covid-19 shots are more
dangerous than the virus itself pole
finds over half of unvaccided Americans
53 believe that covid-19 vaccines pose a
a higher health risk than the virus
itself the view is especially prominent
among Americans who say they're
definitely not getting the vaccine with
75 believing the vaccine is more
dangerous in fact the virus is far more
dangerous out of 243 000 Americans who
died of covet since January 2021 only 1
300 have been unvaccinated still the
Indian Delta variant is persuading some
to get their shots with 22 percent of
unvaccinated respondents saying the
variant was a vaccination motivator
I don't know the the full percentage
numbers but um yeah the the virus is far
more dangerous well you said died from
covet right you read that that phrase
from covet uh died of coven of covet how
many how many people have died of covid
uh let's see out of 243 000 Americans
who have died since January 2021 only 1
300 have been unvaccinated so wait what
200 that's not correct I don't know
these numbers but they're saying that
230 000 people died of covid I've seen
reports that people had coveted in their
system and died of a motorcycle accident
or some other thing with kovid they died
with covid not necessarily of kovid but
that there were no no no that's wrong
that's wrong they wrote the story wrong
the story it's it's they did it wrong
out of 243 000 kova deaths deaths later
on they fix it only 1 300 have occurred
in vaccinated Americans the top said
have been unvaccinated as if to imply
the vaccine was more dangerous that's
that's uh so uh Daily Mail get it get it
get it get an editor I'm nervous when
people say that we're in lockdowns
because we're in shutdowns and I'm
nervous when people say that people died
of covid when they died with a
comorbidity
right now Ian well over the last year in
2020 we had gone through periods of
shutdown and I heard people say lockdown
locked they like that word that button
it's a lock lock it's like they want it
to be yeah it did lockdown but there
were lots of instances of shutdown that
people were calling lockdown let's not
make it worse than it see we don't have
to make it seem worse than it is they're
saying that we will die
Freight it's Freight we're phrasing it's
it's subtle little language twist that
people do to control this narrative
right now you're saying to tell people
to to accept that they're barred from
leaving their homes or going to their
jobs no but I'm saying if that's a
lockdown if there's if an area gets shut
down don't say that it's locked down by
like lock and key just it's just oh
businesses aren't open that doesn't mean
you can't walk around outside so it's
not a locked downstairs right right yeah
that's called apologizing for
authoritarianism no if we say that we
have lockdowns and we keep saying it
then the government will put them into
place and people will passively let it
happen because they're used to lockdowns
we had shutdowns for the most part no we
have the United States we had maybe had
a few instances of things being locked
down but for the most part the United
States was very leniently shut down as
opposed to Australia massively locked
down like you're saying you're drawing
where are you drawing the line when the
police don't let people go outside I
mean they're arresting people for
walking around that happened in the U.S
very very rarely though for the most
part we had lockdowns there were some
instances of it it was very rare and I
argue it violates the kind
because if you tell people that we're
locked down for all of 2020 then when
they actually start locking it down
people will be used to it because they
they thought it was already happening
well I'll tell you this look man
obviously that Daily Mail story was
wrong because it contradicted itself
which is why I always say talk to your
doctor about what's right for you you
know and there's another good reason too
because I got a feeling like whoever
ends up happening in the long run people
are going to come back and they're going
to be like Tim said X or Y and I'm not
going to be the person who's going to be
responsible for your health decision so
by all means you could be in the
comments right now saying Tim is dumb I
would appreciate it great because I
don't want anybody putting the
responsibility on me for your health
decisions yeah nah Sheamus you go talk
to your doctor that's I I have a bunch a
whole bunch for buddies conversations he
was like I'm gonna do everything and I I
had a hidden camera when I was talking
to Tim and I showed it with my doctor I
was like how much can we get for me
Sheamus went to the vitamin and he's
like you should have talked to your life
talk to your lawyer about how much money
we have all the vitamins and he just
grabbed like his seeds a multivitamin
he's just chugging him and he's like
it's healthy Tim said so and I'm like
yeah
so here's the interesting thing though
they say that um
that half of people let me let me let me
see exactly what they said they said
more than half of unvaccinated Americans
believe that that they're more dangerous
than the virus itself well that makes
sense here's well no so I'm gonna pull
up the story this is from uh this is
from UPMC uh University of Pittsburgh
and Carnegie Mellon University
researchers identify groups hesitant
about covid-19 vaccine this is the most
fascinating to me the study says the
largest decrease in hesitancy between
January and may by education group was
in those with a high school education or
less
hesitancy held constant in the most
educated group those with a PhD by May
phds were the most hesitant group while
vaccine hesitancy decreased across
virtually all racial groups black and
Pacific Islanders had the largest
decreases joining Hispanics and Asians
at having lower vaccine hesitancy than
whites in May
why
I have no answer for that well the data
I mean if you listen to you know Peak
Prosperity Chris Martinson if you're
listening to Brett Weinstein and Pierre
card that's wrong there's scientists
that just fish data and the data speaks
for itself know that no no it literally
doesn't we had Chris Martinson on the
show with all due respect he's a very
smart man he's like he's got a PhD and I
think in toxicology and when we talked
with him he said here's 53 studies on
Ivermectin and then I Googled it and
found a whole bunch more saying the
exact opposite it doesn't speak for
itself we'll have to go and do it on the
after show there's some there's some
studies that I've seen that have just
been mind-blowing bro we we literally I
I pulled up studies and there's so
there's studies that say these things
these treatments do nothing and there
are studies saying they do some things
none of these treatments are FDA
approved the point is the data does not
speak for itself well I I disagree I
think this is why phds are are among the
most hesitant is because it's data heavy
it's it comes down to the data I mean
you gotta you gotta look at what was
polio doing to people it was crippling
children the data was showing that
people were little kids were like losing
their ability to walk permanently that's
like
screaming data we haven't seen that kind
of data with this I mean there's been a
lot of illness 600 and what are we at
600 620 000 Dead with that had died with
covid and when they phrase it of covet
that's that's kind of a manipulation
because a lot of it is comorbid and
people have obesity and they die with
like a heart failure but they had
coveted in their system so it gets
logged covet is like the uh the the he
like you know it covet pulls the pin out
and then the train goes off the rails
you know what I mean so it's like people
who may have survived with comorbidities
don't when they get it's tough to say
it's that that's a situation where you
don't know what it would have been
without it because it didn't have it
what the data is saying well you don't
know if they hadn't gotten coveted what
would have happened because they had
gotten coveted I hear from people all
the time they're like hey I read this
about that this that or otherwise and
I'm like I'm gonna read that and then I
find conflicting information from like
legitimate sources and I'm like I can't
draw on Ana's conclusion go talk to your
doctor because I I when Chris Martinson
was here and he said 53 studies I said
great let's pull them up and I pulled
them up I'm like that's really
fascinating and then I Googled other
studies to see if there was a you know a
contradiction sure enough I found like
several many and I'm like I asked them
you know these studies say the opposite
he goes oh well that study was bad and
I'm like yeah how are you going to come
to me and tell me this study is good
this study is bad when they're both
studies okay I'm a Layman and and I can
respect him because I think he's a smart
guy and he knows more about it than I do
and I can respect Brett Weinstein but
then there are many other doctors that I
see writing stories who don't appear
overtly political [ __ ] saying the
inverse I suppose it's just I've seen
Chris Martinson peer Corey Brett
Weinstein Brett's not a doctor not a
virologist he's a biological biologist
but he's a very smart scientist you know
Pierre Corey is a virologist is Chris
Martin son of virologist but bro what
I'm telling you is if you only watch one
thing and then say that must be true the
data doesn't speak for itself when you
can pull up contradictory information
okay maybe maybe yeah you're right data
doesn't speak for itself but I did get
this from reputable sources that's the
reason I'm and I got contradictory
information from my people's sources as
well which we pulled them up on the show
here we go right now on this remember I
remember touching on it I don't remember
like I literally did these studies who
paid these people to do these studies
you see that's the problem when people
say well your organization is no good
because of this that or what but yeah
but your organization I'm like dude that
means literally nothing but the problem
is some organizations will do studies
specifically to derive a specific
results for political reasons people
make observations or determinations or
trust I try my best to avoid doing that
and so that's what this is what guides
most of my work is that if I see some
conservative Guy come out and say that
you know you got to buy your gold and
then the Democrat guy comes out and says
you got to buy silver I'll be like well
we've got two contradictory people
giving contradictory advice can I find
source information to vet which one is
better hey I looked it up Gold's worth
more so when it comes to these studies
you see conflicting studies do you just
dismiss them all or do you go deeper and
try and figure out which studies are
right or which ones are more accurate so
the issue is when you look at a study
what can you really determine about it
there's a doctor named Dr John Smith or
whatever his name is and I'm like okay
so I can look him up and then I find a
LinkedIn for a guy and I'm like okay and
I look up here's this University and
then I find a Dr Jane Doe and I look her
up and I'm like well they both disagree
with each other I can't make a
determination
what am I supposed so what am I supposed
to what am I supposed to tell people
right if there's conflicting information
same when they say buy gold buy silver
you have to kind of do some deep
research to figure out which study is
legit there are people who want to
believe one or the other and they may
have reason to I'm not saying they're
wrong I'm saying I haven't been able to
find anything strong and so therein lies
the big issue it's why I don't
definitively come out and say you must
do X or Y I say talk to someone you
trust in the medical field because when
we have when I see these things you know
when I talk to these like Chris
Martinson he's on the show twice now I'm
like I
you know he I pulled up a study that he
said was was was was positive for
alternate treatments and then I go I
Googled the study and found another
paper that said the methodology was
flawed it was not a good study because
of these reasons then I pulled up a
study saying these alternative
treatments were ineffective and he said
to me oh but those studies are flawed
because they're you know and I'm okay
dude right with all due respect so one
of those those those things are
ineffective because we never tested them
for efficacy no they'll do that
sometimes I'm saying I'm saying we sat
here we have the episode it's on
timcast.com where I was like I can pull
up something saying literally what you
just said in the other direction they
would say that about aspartame they said
there's no evidence aspartame has any
links to cancer because we never studied
aspartame
that's medical logic I'm talking about
logic I'm talking about fact-finding and
determining you know to the best of our
abilities truth and you can argue that
you trust or don't trust a particular
political faction or those who Advocate
first in a certain direction I don't
think that's good enough enough I want
proof now there's a good reason I think
not just the media but we have a big
issue now when the CDC comes out and
says here's a list of things and I'm
like okay well I do have a personal bias
against government for a lot of reasons
but if I can't disprove it that puts me
in a difficult position so why do you
think uh that it's mostly PhD people
that are that's why I said I have no
answer it's hard to know also because
you don't know what their phds are in
that's right it could be it could be
like I think who said this before was it
you were saying like it could be like
feminist dancers yeah it could be like a
PhD in lesbian poetry I have no idea
right so we have we have we have no idea
that's why I say it's interesting but
I'm seeing a lot of people highlight
that as if that's evidence of something
and I'm like it's just a group of people
maybe they're activists who hate Donald
Trump because they're in universities
and how many people was pulled here was
like 2 000 people
you're also you're so what you're doing
this is data from people who are saying
that they were already against getting
the vaccine it's probably I mean it
could very well just be the case that if
someone has a PHD their opinion was more
likely to be backed up with statistic
sticks again whether they're ones you
would agree with or disagree with in the
first place and so that locks them and
do it more firmly or they're more likely
to be stodgy and stubborn exactly well
and I think that plays into it as well
um
and that's exactly part of why I said
statistics whether you do agree whether
you would agree with them or disagree
with them I think people with phds
people whose brains work more quickly
are more conventionally intelligent tend
to be a bit more prideful and they're
also better at convincing themselves of
things here's what I'm saying to me a
PhD is just a Twitter check mark in real
life like right I don't really trust at
all that much but here's here's what I'm
saying all the information we present
you can take into consideration however
you see fit but I if I can't make a
determination I'm not going to make one
so I I need I need sources before I come
out and say something and you know I get
things wrong every so often or jump the
gun it happens so I'm far from perfect
but I try to avoid things if I can't
prove it
your point about studies is interesting
because I feel like they do this every
other month with dietary stuff fats are
bad fats are good use this oil don't use
this oil this is going to kill it you're
going to get cancer from Coffee coffee
is good for your heart coffee cures
depression for women what am I supposed
to think so I think that in the end
really boils down to one individual
rights and two common sense and like I
don't even know what to tell you it's
not like the whole read the studies
thing because you're not going to
understand all talk to your doctor you
know you know who yes and you know who
you should which doctor I don't think
you should talk to is Doctor
you know we got this story we got the
story from we got this story we got the
story we got the story from Reuters U.S
plans to give extra covid-19 shots to
at-risk Americans fauci says that is the
third shot for people who are in at-risk
groups if you are immunocompromised
people like cancer survivors those who
are HIV positive they are saying that
they are trying to rush through approval
for your third shot now over in Israel
we have this from Voice of America after
another covet Spike Israel launches
third vaccine dose they say Israel has
become the first country to distribute a
third dose of the coveted vaccine
offering the extra jab to anyone over
60. Israeli Health experts say the
effectiveness of the current vaccine
declines with time and the third shot
will serve as a booster the move comes
as virus rights in Israel are on the
increase now
this is crazy viral video which they say
is a report from Israel's Channel 13
where they say in this Twitter and this
Twitter which I this tweet which I'm
I've not confirmed a translation that
the hospitalization rates are
overwhelmingly those who have been
vaccinated in Israel is saying we are
not finding this to be effective now I
don't know if that's true yeah well and
also we have to know what percentage the
population is vaccinated to because if
an overwhelming majority of the
population is vaccinated in an
overwhelming pup you know majority are
in the hospital it's proportional then
we could say well it doesn't seem to be
working in this instance but if a
majority are in the hospitals whereas an
overwhelming majority is vaccinated then
it seems it would be working to some
extent or you could make that argument
so we don't really know they say an
Israeli study showed effectiveness of
the covid vaccine decline from 95 to 80
oh wow or even less against the Delta
variant neither the U.S nor the EU has
yet recommended a third shot but most
Israeli doctors say they do not believe
it will do any harm now we have we had a
story we pulled up the other day from
timcast.com that shows I think it was
like Pfizer and ashrazeneca to be like
92 and 96 percent effective against the
Delta variant so all I can do is tell
you this
talk to your doctor because I don't you
know I I know for for those on the live
show like right now it's more repetitive
but in the segments like yeah you know
so we have to say it
um because I don't know what this means
I really really don't Israel is making a
lot of claims that a lot of people in
the U.S are shocked to hear very
interesting and and don't know if they
want to believe to be completely honest
that they're that you know what Israel
is saying about the effectiveness so
here's why I bring this up
um not not only is that happening but
the World Health Organization is calling
for a temporary moratorium on vaccine
booster shots because they want to
prioritize global distribution of the
vaccine to poorer Nations okay so I have
no idea
um yeah I can tell you this it sounds
like humans run around like these
organizations are like chickens with
their head cut off is that true though
do you cut a chicken sound if it runs
around yes I'm not sure I mean you're
the one with chickens Tim I'm not I'm
not cutting their heads off you know he
just doesn't want to admit it on stream
because you know Petey's going to get it
that's true uh my family he'll get
canceled right yeah yeah it's true
though don't get canceled my family
raised chickens and yes this is the
thing
yeah I'm curious I am curious what
percentage of the population in Israel
is vaccinated what percentage of new
cases did they set were say were
vaccinated people well that's there's a
tweet and I don't speak Hebrew so I
can't really confirm that anyway you
know but people are claiming that
there's a doctor who says it's like the
overwhelming majority of the covid
patients in the hospitals have been
vaccinated that is fascinating yeah but
again I can't hear from any of that
stuff all I know is that uh fauci is
rushing out a third shot here in America
for people who are either compromised
the the eviction moratorium was
illegally a new one was illegally put in
place and the unemployment checks are
going out so it smells like uh lockdown
I guess you know they say if it walks
like a lockdown you know acts like a
lockdown and sounds like a lockdown then
it's probably a lockdown right yeah
exactly I'm hearing from a Reuters their
numbers say that the number of doses in
Israel administered has been 11 million
and so if that's at two doses per person
that's 63.2 percent of the country being
vaccinated it's a little bit higher than
the US I think I think the US's rate was
uh like what 49 or something like that
the United States is right of
vaccinations well I have some data here
saying that they asked um
adults and they found that seven in ten
adults said they have already gotten it
or are getting it as soon as possible so
something like 67 have already gotten it
and uh a three more percent say they're
going to get it as soon as possible
Australia is like 18 why is they've
gotten vaccinated yeah I think they just
don't trust their government I guess it
could also Australian is not as I I
think Australia's population is much
more spread out um
I think maybe if if your government is
not treating you very well then you're
probably not going to be too happy okay
no it's it's uh it's higher right now
okay oh no no yeah fully vaccinated 16
whoa wow that's low
wow well at least one dose is 34.2
percent oh
wow that's so bad where in Australia so
that's of the population yeah of the
population 16.3 are fully vaccinated wow
that's that's really really low it's
abysmal wow yeah yeah why is that that's
like the most heavily cracked down
country on Earth that's probably why it
could win assembly crack down upon it I
also think it's the population density
uh it is really uh it's it's something
partially populated sparsely populated
so the numbers I have here are three
people per squared kilometer in the
United States the average population
density is 94 people
um yeah but they've got cities dude no
I'm not saying they don't but I don't I
think that more of their population
lives in rural areas
it's tough to say based on average
numbers but
I think their population is more spread
out than ours is their population is
what like 25 million or something it's
not Betty yeah so we have 10 times yeah
so I they have big cities you know that
I and they're and they've got military
deployed to enforce the lockdown no I'm
not saying they don't have big cities
but I'm saying overall they're less
densely populated which means there are
more people who live further away from
other people
you don't think Australia's average
population is less dense than I'm saying
Australia like two to one yeah Australia
is as big as the U.S with a tenth of the
population so it's not that they're
living
it's that there's a big open Outback
desert nothing in the middle of the
continent okay what was U.S population
let's say 20 how many people 370 million
no density density oh the population
density
um 94 people per square in Australia was
like nine oh actually Australia's
Australia so so the United States is but
the United States is information I just
gave you is Miles so if you look in
kilometers it's 36 people per kilometer
squared words right so three people ten
times the population yeah I know that
makes sense very similar why is the
vaccine rate in Australia 16 did you
pull the vaccination rate for the U.S
actually that's it well I think I had
some numbers pulled up from earlier and
it said again about 70 percent of people
have already gotten it or are getting it
as soon as possible wow wow no no no no
no no no it's fifth it's
50.4 of the of people in the United
States are fully vaccinated
165 million people at least one dose is
58.7
Australia
16.3 I think when you crack down when
you start arresting people for not
wearing masks and you deploy military
people are not going to trust yeah it
would be less likely I'm also curious
what Australia is like culturally too I
I wonder if they're as divided as the
United States is or if there's a more
unified front in terms of the skepticism
that they have towards government
mandates not sure well authoritarianism
this is why it doesn't work because you
lose you you lose the faith and the
confidence of the people and so we were
having this conversation I think it was
um I don't know if it was with vosh and
Charlie in the bonus segment or
something about like uh authoritarianism
is effective in that you can mandate
things really really quickly and that's
technically true the problem is it
derails itself it falls apart because if
you don't have confidence of the people
the system can't be supported the the
government is an imaginary construct of
people's confidence like why is a dollar
valuable if you showed a dollar to an
alien they'd be like it's I don't need
this what am I gonna do with it now gold
they might understand like ah you know a
conductor I can do something with this
money they're going to be like sure I
don't know what you you like this they
might think it's a really cool picture
yeah like oh it's a picture and they put
on the wall there's different kinds of
it's not functional of authoritarianism
too there's the authority of one man
which is like totalitarian you know
dictatorship and then there's the
authority of the of a constitution like
a written document and that's also a
form of authoritarianism no it isn't
it's really not but it is a form of
Authority so they they basically got all
authorities authoritarians right the
founding fathers are generally used
I would like to explain to you what
Authority is go for it when a police
officer in New York says you can't stand
there that's a frozen Zone which is what
they do that is not that is
authoritarianism that is them just
arbitrarily deciding I can do this you
want to know what real Authority is
Sheamus drops to the ground ah and
there's blood spring everywhere and a
doctor looks you in the eye and says put
your put your hands on his neck right
now what would you say
absolutely just do it exactly if you
were out in the street and you saw
somebody hurt and there was a guy he's
like I'm a doctor you come here now put
your hands here you would not think
twice exactly because you know that's
what real Authority is but if there was
some crackpot guy on a on a in a
rickshaw and he was had people pulling
him and he was like you there you know
come here and kneel so I can walk on
your back because I and leave my Richard
you'd be like get out of here that's
insane and then if he threatened you
with a weapon to make you do it
authoritarian
I think that the reason I brought up the
founding fathers again is because they
established like a I don't know two
decades of massive authoritarianism in
order to install a constitution that
they could step back from and release
their Authority what do you mean by that
like they were like George Washington an
ultimate authority over the land they
would have made him King he could have
become a monarch
and and big that doesn't mean
authoritarianism though but that they
they functioned authoritarian
authoritatively to to build the
Constitution to seize the the million
Washington was given his troops
vaccinated against their will you know
like pure on martial law authoritarian
Crackdown to win the Revolutionary War
that's war and then instead of one guy
maintaining authoritarianism being like
and now this is legal but now it's not
and now that's the new thing we just
built a set of laws that could take over
for us the fact that they gave up power
and enacted the Constitution shows it
was never authoritarian it was just it
was just I think you can use
authoritarianism for good they seem to
have
I I but I don't think it was
authoritarianism I don't think that that
falls in in line with it it was it was
hey we want freedom oh no they're
attacking us quick everyone come
together here's what we have to do to
survive like if the house started
burning down and I grabbed you and
dragged you out of the house is that
authoritarianism technically no come on
no I mean if if it hit the fan and you
had to like take control of everything
passed out from smoke inhalation but he
hasn't chosen to leave so I'm not an
authoritarian I'm leaving him in the
building
it's freedom to sleep during the fire I
mean it's interesting so so the word
authority and the word author come from
the same place which is Creator someone
creates something they have authority
over it or if they have given you
they've delegated The Authority uh over
their creation to another person than
that person has authority over it um and
of course it comes ultimately from God
creating the universe delegating
authority to specific Civil Authorities
but a belief in Authority is not the
same as a belief that
unbridled authoritarianism is acceptable
yeah do you when you think of unbridled
authoritarianism do you think of it as
like dictatorial yeah so I would say
usurpation anytime an authority
structure absorbs the role of a smaller
more vulnerable Authority structure when
it doesn't have to do so I would call
that authoritarianism so basically
anytime subsidiarity is violated so I
believe that there are all sorts of
authority structure Authority structures
across Humanity so you have the the
family structure which is an authority
structure you have the father at the
head of the household and then you also
have local governments state governments
a national government and if one higher
authority quote-unquote higher authority
in that hierarchy comes down and takes a
role which is proper to one of the lower
authorities so for example if the state
starts to interfere with family life in
ways that are proper to a father I
believe that's authoritarianism because
somebody is taking the rightful
Authority away from one and giving
Authority which is not due to another to
them what's interesting I think when
they have to own only if they don't have
to and you got to Define what does that
mean if someone feels like they have to
step in and take the authority like what
I can I can expect a virus make someone
think I can explain to authoritarianism
and libertarianism somewhat uh with a
great way um so the Democrats right now
believe the economy is going good why
because the authority told them and they
have strict adherence to the authority
which says this is what you must do they
say okay the economy is good yes sir
Trump supporters were told by Trump to
get the vaccine and they said no
Marion is enough yeah we live in the
kind of self-authored society the
Constitution has sort of supposedly
self-authored by the by us we the people
we are a freedom loving people but we
are losing that what interests me is
that they They seized authoritarian
dictatorship for a short period of time
in order to create a self-authored
society or also it's a sweet thing and
plus people could have just fled I guess
they've been cowards and I don't know
England yeah it was it was it was a lot
harder back then I suppose but they were
loyalists they were people who said no
to the revolution
that made me think of if we hadn't had
was it South Carolina the slave states
if they hadn't joined us Not only would
they just not have been in their
fighting they would have been all
loyalists you know what we're really
funny though is that they would have had
to abolish slavery sooner if they
remained with the crown but this is
really interesting actually in that
regard because I talked about this
because a lot of people have said If
America never declared independence
slavery would have ended 20 years
earlier and I'm like I'm not sure that's
true that's true at all imagine the
crown of Britain said we're mandating in
1833 the end of slavery the southern
states would have declared independence
but the whole British ending slavery
things kind of a fallacy because they
did what was called enclosure I was just
watching if they're in Kings in
General's YouTube channel about this
yesterday enclosures basically where the
Lords of the land seized the land from
every all the civilians 90
99.98 of of British land is owned by
like .01 of the population since like
the 1600s since they started enclosure
well and also if the United States was
still under British rule the economic
and political incentives would be
entirely different from the crown from
what they were when England wasn't
overseeing the United States and decided
to end slavery so I don't think you
could say that if we stayed with the
crowd and slavery would have ended soon
I don't think you could possibly know
that but they might have let it roll in
in the Americas yeah because it was
making them so much money yeah they
would just colonize or because or
because they they feared some kind of
Revolt right because the southern states
seceded and revolted
um so I have no reason to believe that
the British government wouldn't have the
foresight to say oh that will probably
happen or could happen I think so to me
it's it's not something you could
possibly I loved my English homeless man
but the British government terrifies me
a monarchy in today's age
our government scares me a lot more but
I mean you see Britain like the the the
the Commonwealth is struggling Canada
and Australia are are and New Zealand
are getting messed up right now by
Authority and then they got a new god
king at the top like
it's crazy yeah but it's not like the
crown actually does anything yeah it's a
ceremony it's all behind they own land
is what they do yeah they basically
control everything through ownership we
got we have that in the United States
too bro
there's a lot of times Trinity uh in
like New York one of the largest
landowners no I didn't know that Bureau
of Land Management is the Vatican in
China yeah they have a lot of land
yeah that's how you do it I guess you
own the land like uh like Ray Crock you
know like we're not doing anything we
just own the land yeah own the land
under the McDonald's that's an active
process to own land yeah yeah
yeah will we uh
we yeah I wonder what the future holds
for us yeah I don't know it's
interesting there we go we're 700 and
like real healthy and stuff live till
700 and be real healthy well once you
get the 5 000th jab you might make it
yeah you're gonna make it 5 000. well
look to be fair they've been saying
since the beginning they were expecting
to be like a yearly thing yeah like a
flu shot yeah exactly I mean they've
said that they think this is going to be
like a seasonal flu the issue is they
didn't force me to get the flu shot you
know like you walk into Walgreens and
they're like would you like to and it's
like you know maybe yeah I guess yeah
yeah I went to the doctor once I told
the story like you know he gave me like
four or five shots or whatever yeah yeah
all at once there's an entirely
different culture around it people don't
shame you for not getting the flu yeah I
know people that would get the flu shot
and then get the flu because they their
immune systems would be so so beat up by
the shot that then they wouldn't be
eating healthy and then they'd end up
getting sick anyway so what's the point
the problem with the flu shot is that we
develop it in conjunction with Australia
because their flu season is ahead of
ours sometimes they have a different
strain of the flu than we have so by the
time the flu shot comes here and we're
using it we're like oh this will work
for our strain right sometimes sometimes
not like there was one year I remember
at the hospital they gave us all the
shot it was great it was wonderful tons
of people still got the flu it was
something like 30 effective because the
Australian strain just wasn't very much
like the American strain I remember
reading a while ago this was before
covid this is before anyone was really
talking about this before there was any
you know seeming controversy over
vaccines as far as I could tell but I
remember reading that flu vaccines were
becoming less effective on a yearly
basis and it was a serious problem that
had to be dealt with I haven't heard
anything I mean I think the the the the
discourse surrounding vaccines has
clearly moved on to other issues if that
is the case but it's becoming the
challenge is I think one of the reasons
you see these stories where people think
the vaccine is more dangerous is because
of the authoritarianism of the media and
the left the overstate the cathedral
whatever you want to call it one of the
people who always lie to you tell you
something's good you're not going to
believe them and they've discredited
themselves over the past few years like
Russia gate is is you know you know what
for everybody's listening if you ever
get you ever get somebody who's like you
know oh you you believe that stuff be
like Russia yeah I'm sorry like you've
lost all credibility in the New York
Times The Washington Post and and CNN
and all these MSNBC were screaming
Russia for years and it was all bunk you
lost me dude sorry and also like there
is precedent for them lying and moving
the goal post about this as well this
very situation two weeks to slow the
spread oh the idea is we just want
people locked down so that the hospitals
don't get overwhelmed with new patients
and everyone forgot if that's the case
yeah everyone forgot about that it was
two weeks to slow the spread and the
whole point was 15 15 days 15 days I'm
sorry so a day over two weeks to slow
the spread because we didn't want
hospitals to get overwhelmed and what
happened they didn't get overwhelmed
exactly but did we stop at two weeks
unfortunately so we've already been lied
to about this and the narrative has
changed even if you don't want to say we
were lied to the narrative clearly
changed the goal post has moved so
people have no reason to believe it's
not going to move if they go and get the
vaccine or do whatever else they're
being told that these people would scold
you and talk down to you for not taking
their word for it after they've
repeatedly misrepresented what the
future would be if we were to take their
word for it is ridiculous the lack of
self-awareness is astounding even for
them this is why I always say
doctor the droplets
because because listen [ __ ] your
droplets I don't care the politics there
are people who make money off of shock
content be it somebody who is like in a
hospital about going I wish I got the
vaccine or somebody being like my legs
don't work it's like the people are
going to find the stories that get the
clicks and that's why you need to find
someone you trust who's done the
research and there are people who tell
me that they don't trust their doctors
I'm like then you need a good doctor
dude lots of doctors it's okay to travel
from Doctor to doctor they call them
second opinion get a second opinion
exactly it's the age of like multiple
opinions get lots and lots of doctors
opinions well just just make sure that
you trust they've done their research
that they're qualified because it's
insane to me that anyone would would
think that I'm implying you go to a
quack doctor in an alley like no I'm
saying you go someone and you ask some
questions say here's what I saw what do
you think and here's what I said earlier
like if you see a story show them yeah
see see what they think yeah exactly
exactly exactly because if there's
nothing to it then your doctor should
generally be able to explain to you well
sometimes times these things happen or
whatever it is but but the statistics
I've seen in my research shows that it
is safe if it is right so let me let me
let me let me add um the doctor I had in
my neighborhood we knew our doctor yes
that's huge I was about to bring that up
actually it's not just talking to your
doctor and it's not just talking to a
doctor who you've known or not in fact
because because maybe you don't have a
doctor who you go to primarily it is
really helpful to just have friends who
are doctors or like a life who's a
doctor folks oh yeah but if you have
friends who are doctors who you
genuinely trust who you aren't
necessarily seeing that you're going to
instill with about this stuff let's go
to Super Chat all right smash that like
button go to timcast.com we'll have a
bonus hit us with the super chats
boys and girls be a bonus segment at
timcast.com coming up around 11 or so
p.m so make sure you remember there for
all the good fun where we get spicy but
uh for now just smash that like button
let's read some super chats spicy
tonight Tim Christian Jim gotchian says
screwing landlords over is on purpose
Black Rock can afford the losses but Mom
and Pop landlords can't and must sell or
get foreclosed on great reset well yeah
I mean whether it's intentional that is
certainly bound to be one of the
long-term consequences here miso trash
says happy birthday Lids thank you
appreciate that Michelle Kramer says hey
Tim cast team Seamus have you seen
tolstoy's Christian Anarchist argument
what do you think of the Prophet
Samuel's warning against government
um yeah so I'm definitely not an
anarchist I'm I and if I'm not mistaking
what they're referring to with the
prophet Samuel is when the people asked
for a king then there are certainly
arguments in that there are certainly
warnings that people should heed about
the state and the overstepping of
authority but as I mentioned earlier
Authority comes by definition from what
the word means from the author from the
Creator and the ultimate author of
things is God so as Christians what we
believe and I should say as Catholics
more specifically
is there are rightly ordered Authority
structures including Civil Authorities
because scripture also says that the
king does not wield The Sword in vain
Render unto Caesar
Etc so as Christians we do believe that
there should be some uh obedience to
Civil Authorities as long as they're not
asking you to do anything which is
contrary to the faith or Reason Matthew
let me be clear by faith the reason I'm
saying it in with respect to like a
well-formed conscience because it's a
very slippery slope to say well I don't
agree with these reasons Matthew Edmond
says when are we going to get a freedom
Tunes movie oh my goodness I would love
to do something like that I would need
to figure out the funding what I'm
trying to do right now is get Freedom
Tunes to be a more well-oiled machine so
I can take on some more of these
projects so I've mentioned before we
work on other projects I have other
clients but I really want to get Freedom
Tunes specifically to be more steady so
I can step away and do some of these
expansionists things like a a film or
television show or something like that
so one thing we need in order to do that
isn't just the crowdfunding patreon.com
freedomtunes but animators if you or
anyone you know is an animator please
reach out to us can I give them your
jobs
I know because I don't have an email
address that I give to the public we
can't go through extra emails all right
fine all right I guess so Tim doesn't
love me
um
I'm trying to well I'm not sure where to
uh because I don't have um yeah I mean
just tweet at me uh that's right at
Seamus Cognito Twitter actually my DMs
are open at Sheamus underscore Coughlin
just if you or anyone you know is an
animator please reach out because we're
looking to hire more people so that we
can do those kinds of products I want to
see people that have mastered Sheamus's
art form yeah I was thinking this a
couple nights ago like oh yeah I bet
people are like just really good at
drawing your art exactly and you could
hire the last video fixing leftist memes
was great thank you so much I love the
one where the mug and it's like don't
but I tweeted it it said don't confuse
your Google search the medical degree
and then you changed it to my my
duckduck go search and then changed it
to don't confuse your Google search with
my Google search that was the best one
because thank you that's literally what
it is yeah that's what it is 90 of the
time well both yes go watch that video
actually I won't there's more to it I
won't spoil the joke all right let's
let's read some more secrets crazy arms
like this sometimes on your cartoon can
you have them doing that while their
arms are at their sides sometimes all
right just for you Kendall herd says
last year Adam said happy birthday to me
can I get another happy birthday from
the Tim cast crew happy birthday happy
birthday
to you yeah happy birthday buddy X
Runner says leftists make a great
argument for anarchical capitalism
that's right
all right let's see
Jake mahaney says can you guys improvise
a fauci v Trump skit live please also
happy birthday Lydia we definitely
improvise the Trump fee foul Chase get
and there will be we will definitely be
advising more skits yeah so the the
Mordor one from like last week yeah that
I released last week but we did that a
while ago but it was because I was uh I
did a Joe Biden in Mordor as a joke we
can't even get into that because that's
going to be a really good video we can't
spoil that remember no I think you
started I think you started with foxy
we're like can I stayed into the flames
and I don't know dude I was dying and
they were like all right Lord
we have to make this a video I'll just
yeah just fouchy as elrond that's so
good do it Trump cast it into the Wuhan
wet Market such an incredible Trilogy
all right let's see
okay spare climber says hey Tim my
girlfriend is a nurse at Banner and is
quitting over the vax Mandate could you
look into the situation here in AZ adult
thanks absolutely love the show guys
I Know Better Health my girlfriend's a
nurse all right
let's see uh call for President says the
show isn't showing up in YouTube under
the timcast channel huh pretty sure
that's why there's so few viewers happy
birthday Lydia keep searching expanding
Earth Ian interesting I don't know about
that did you see it on the timcast
Channel I didn't see it until two
minutes before we went live and it was
up for like 10 minutes yeah but see what
they do is they don't show it to certain
people I definitely do see it on the but
so like they don't have their vaccine
passport if they haven't verified that
they're vaccinated a bunch of Tim cast
videos and click like on a bunch of them
and the YouTube algorithm will start
sorting it to the top of your thing so
yeah
Peter Gunn says I just watched a video
from Greg Foreman showing The Young
Turks and daily beasts trying to smear
you it was pathetic you're getting big
man keep it up yeah these things happen
it was hilarious I I I I love it when
when people are like I'm going to try
and find everyone who hates you to say
bad things about you and it's like
people don't like you people red but it
read like satire it was crazy it was
really bad I was reading the article I
was like what is this this is like too
over the top is that a doctor segment I
had a lot of people say that it was just
like hard to read because it was so long
so it was really long no I so I was like
jumping around in it I definitely it was
very long and it was all the same
garbage but there were a few lines in
there man that I saw that just stuck out
to me that I thought were hilarious well
you know people they they they try but I
don't I don't dwell on these things yeah
that's fair that's because the way I see
it is like they're trying to distract
you they're like we're on a path and
that path is expanding it's growing it's
successful and the last thing I need is
to waste time with distractions I get it
good for you we got we got to do this
DND show the Lions don't care for the
opinion of this and we did hire a DM a
dungeon master is here so thank you guys
so much for sending me you're an
exorcist for you yes stuff
yeah it's going to be good
Dr Roller Gator says happy birthday
Lydia you're the best thank you Lydia is
the best happy birthday we're happy for
you
Gator oh look at this debt collector
says hey Tim I just want to let you know
the governor of Virginia just mandated
that all state employees must show proof
of the vax or be forced to get tested
see that makes no sense yeah
if they're saying that they're still
breakthrough cases but if you're
vaccinated that you don't gotta get yeah
tested yeah but if you're not vaccinated
you do got to get tested it's kind of
like but you're still you still have an
open door like if the goal is to secure
a building and you're like people are
less likely to go through this door than
this door so we're only going to watch
this door and I'm like So eventually
people will still get in the one door
like I don't know that makes no sense to
me dude
all right let's see what do we got here
Gothic Extravaganza says question for
Sheamus if the debunked are so far
removed from society how do they receive
communion also happy birthday Lydia oh
the debunkers the bunkers yeah that's it
they have um so they they have a priest
who will visit them on occasion who
comes and he's he's extremely
intellectual so they will not catch the
stupid from him I can't give you the
name he's a very famous very intelligent
priest and he just goes and he uh
dispenses he distributes the the
Eucharist to them but that's a great
question because they could not be as uh
brilliant of debunkers if they were not
in touch with Corey Corey Cass says with
how fast you can talk you should be an
Auctioneer rather than those weird ad
voices this 20 can be the first bid on
whatever you're auctioning what a
reaction tickets we do have an auction
system which is going to be launched on
the website at some point and we're
going to auction off stuff like we got
special custom colorway shoes oh yeah
that everybody who works here got a pair
of I think and uh then we've got like
drawings that we're collecting of every
all of all the guests it was incredible
yeah they're really amazing portraits
those we're going to hold on to a fairly
long time maybe at some point we'll
auction them off as like a fundraiser or
something we're also going to be doing
the auction system was built for uh for
tickets to the to the compound to hang
out at our events so that there's going
to be a handful of first come first
serve for everybody who's a 25 member or
more and then there's going to be
auction based because it's not like we
can invite the whole world to this it's
not a public venue or anything so we
actually are really Limited in how we do
it and then there's an option for like
people who don't have time to sit around
refreshing waiting for the post to
appear and then the people who pay more
who are refreshing so it's like you know
we're bouncing it
Eamon says happy birthday Lydia mine was
on the third yeah we are both Leos
Sheamus love your work my favorite video
is the mostly peaceful Maxine Waters
thank you so much good stuff God bless
you
let's see
California just mandated all healthcare
workers must be vaccinated as well as
all Hospital visitors this may be the
last straw for me staying in California
I think it's hilarious all the people
who are still in New York when I've been
saying like get out of the Cities now
they're like oh no I can't believe this
is happening and I'm lying I can
absolutely and I'll tell this anything
that keeps a sensible person such as
this particular viewer out of California
pushes them out it's probably a good
thing I think there's a silver lining
here
okay but just please well I assume if
he's watching your show he won't but
just please don't vote the way most
Californians vote when you leave
California yes Louis Junior Ramo says
Tim Poole independent party for
president 2024. quote defund the police
guns for all yes we should you know we
do we turn all the police departments
into uh Department of Gun Services
the buildings are already there you've
already got staff they have many of them
have had basic training with weapons and
you you walk in and you fill out the
form like you know this is who I am I
can prove who I am in here I'm getting
my first my free gun we got to do that
just be like I know a lot of people are
like that's gun tracking and I'm like
well what if someone comes and gets two
guns
you know we can let them have two guns
too yeah but we're not social what's the
deal bro you know what you don't know
what his needs are someone goes in there
and they need two guns just let him have
two guns if there's one thing our taxes
should be funding no I'm kidding if
taxes and look if the government was in
control of Distributing guns we'd have a
shortage yeah
more than fine with not giving two guns
I don't think the government should give
anyone a gun yep
CeCe Covey says if legalized a machine
gun would cost you what four grand you
can rent a U-Haul and drive it down uh
yeah I'm not going to read the rest of
that one
that was going yeah we'll see where
that's going Levi says Ian you made a
metaphor weeks ago at the Cleveland
Browns and you're from Ohio are you a
Browns fan go Browns I used to be it was
pain it was like masochistic though it
was like 12 years of loss terrible it
was like 22 years of loss sad I thought
uh what's his name Tim Couch was going
to get us there Barney Boyle says what's
the deal with Michael malice style
anarchists
um like real anarchists what's the deal
was there more to the commentary
with Michael Myers that's all I got Ian
I can't pronounce that says not gonna
lie I think the beanie look needs to go
in the near future what uh I'm gonna let
you guys uh know something
um
you know what
I do this because I want to do it that's
it
that's it that's it yeah exactly I don't
wear suits I never did I never wanted to
and I don't do things I don't feel like
doing and if I didn't feel like doing
this show I wouldn't do it
that's it the upside is it's gonna look
really good in wigs what if I I'm just
saying like I'm not gonna I just do what
I feel like doing I'm not gonna change
myself for any kind of norms or
structures whatever it's
if it got to a point where like what I
did wasn't effective then I just take my
van down to the room and go fishing
people were like keep the beanie on Tim
keep the beanie on would you be like no
I'm taking it off no I'd be like I'm
just going to do what I feel like doing
what if I just started wearing a suit
every show then I was a fancy one and
then exactly and then everyone's like
well this guy's wearing a suit he must
be that I might start wearing headbands
and then YouTube changed the name to
Sheamus cast IRL because they're like
there must be a mistake the guy in the
suit must be the podcast host here and
then The Daily Beast started writing
about me they're like we're so sorry to
actually is this guy in the suit he's
the problem it's not Tim General kale
says can't wait to see a social worker
try talking down a six foot four 300
pound man wielding a sword while he's
covered in dookie how does that make you
feel dude well this is the thing I've
said this before the whole social worker
thing all it's going to do is create a
two-tier system because the people who
are calling the police for reasons that
would necessitate a social worker tend
or you know supposedly necessitate a
social worker rather than a police
officer tend to be people in high higher
income areas where you don't have as
much of a reason to call the police
because there aren't dangerous people so
what do you end up with well you end up
with a situation where the social
workers are being called in the wealthy
suburbs and in the inner city people
call the police because that's where
they're generally dealing with more
actual emergencies and so the funding
for social workers gets diverted to the
suburbs because that's where they're all
going and the funding for the police
departments get diverted to the inner
cities and you end up with a two-tier
system
the people dealing with brutality uh and
you know police misconduct are going to
be the people in the inner cities not
the people getting the the um the social
workers that's exactly how it's going to
shake out
is it day 512 of the of the the lockdown
I don't know
I don't know it's March of 2020. so yes
it's something it's over it's yeah it's
well over Europe and a half I I think
512 sounds about right yeah
I thought it was 15 days yeah oh but
then it's been a really long 15 days
yeah
Dorsey Woods says so I'm going to take
your guns and police then continue to
spend thousands on personal security
because my life is more valuable than
that of you peasants yes happy birthday
Lids Tim look for me in your pitch's
emails very cool that's basically what
they do yep
Bynum Lee says Tim I work for a large
gun manufacturer and we are understaffed
and overworked trying to fill demands
for handguns wow some lines have been
working 60 hours a week plus optional
weekends wow man crazy
that's crazy yo well if it's any if it's
any consolation to the incredibly
difficult schedule you are doing very
important work absolutely yep
Ryan Wales says we should ban all people
with the last names bush from holding
public office what a beautiful world it
would be okay yeah yes please clap yeah
Jeb exclamation point Nate Parrott says
dude Ian yes the U.S isn't invaded
because there's a gun behind every blade
of grass if we could arm everyone P.S I
had to pull off to the side of the road
and park to send this happy belated
birthday list awesome thanks for being
safe be careful yeah
all right let's see
Braden T says if a bad guy flees the U.S
into Canada different police forces with
different laws and tactics come together
to work out a solution why couldn't
private security agencies do the same
Dave Smith 2024. yeah I was gonna they
could yeah that's not what I said if if
Little Johnny from Hillside where they
pay the hillside security goes into
valleyside and steals the the the the
the Amulet of uh of Geeks there you go
sure is that a real thing from someone I
think it's from Baldur's Gate okay and
it's worth five grand and he goes to
this town and then the valley side
police come over saying he's got our
thing
the hillside police are sworn and paid
to protect the residents of Hillside and
they're going to be like we don't know
we don't care these this family pays us
not only that the family of the kid can
be alike we're paying you protect us
from these people they're lying so
cooperation would be difficult because
of competing Financial interests the
thing about the United States and Canada
is that the governments have treaties
and they don't care about you as a
peasant the issue is when Hillside
security is a small entity that operates
only in this one place without the
without the support of the people they
don't exist so they could cooperate
absolutely yeah but it's it's basically
when you know there's there's two groups
I've seen it over and over and over
again the the leftists complain all day
and night about how cops aren't held
accountable but then they say snitches
get stitches yep bro if you're telling
people not to write anybody out why do
you why do you complain when cops don't
do it that's exactly the ideology you're
espousing so there you go
amen
okay let's see thousand foot deep end
says Ian's correct my former HPD
Sergeant aunt said domestic disturbance
calls are the most dangerous yesterday
in my hometown a cop was shot multiple
times while responding to one wow the
officer survived and the suspect was
arrested today you're going into their
house which is also very threatening to
them you know they're already heightened
and enraged so it's a really
crazy stoker roylett says I've gotten
out of more tickets by being respectful
dome lights on glove box is open hands
on steering wheel AA book and Bible on
passenger seat pictures of my kids on
dash happy birthday Lydia I got you
something real nice
I don't think you should open your glove
box
but I'm not sure how the rules work on
that one I've I've heard stories where
if you open your glove box your your
um consenting to a search or something
like that an entire car search yep
really yeah I've heard I've heard I've
never heard that I think that maybe
though if they ask you to open your
glove box and you comply then they say
he agreed to let the car be searched and
then they can broadly search your car I
don't know if that's true it's actually
really crazy because I think the
exclusionary rule means like the cop
can't even look in the window
hmm like that was there was a story in
Chicago something about whether the cop
pulled somebody over and then looked
through the window and saw something and
they were like you can't do that because
you weren't you have the right to search
the vehicle oh okay you know cops do
they pull you over and they go Hey sir
yes I smell pot out of the car dude it's
like dude I hit a skunk a mile back is
ridiculous no but no it's it's insane
that you could just because how can you
prove that later Well why'd you search a
scar I smelled weed okay you don't need
any proof for that that's so funny I had
a cop do that to me I was getting home
late because I do post-production after
the show he pulled me over because I
rolled a stop sign he followed me to my
house it's great he's like have you been
drinking and he was like have you been
drinking and I was like no I was at work
like I literally just left work like
half an hour ago and he's like okay I
was like what the heck I didn't realize
that was the thing they did until that
last well asking you if you've been
drinking is different from saying yeah
I had a cop pull me over and then walk
up the car and say good he's like he's
like a good evening sir oh whoa whoa I
smell marijuana and I was like what
are you kidding dude I don't smoke you
don't and he was like out of the vehicle
and then I was like excuse me he said
out of the vehicle now I was like got
out of the vehicle and then it's a long
story I told it before but yeah that
happens yeah that's horrible Christopher
Knowles says used to be very liberal
took a world wars history class in
college and changed over a quarter wow
ignorance goes a long way corporate
media is America's platonic uh platonic
cave shout out to M Harris's book cow
pigs Wars and witches hmm
all right
all right let's see what we got
flick store entertainment says Tim the
small business administration gives
grants to business owners but people
don't know what they are doing yeah I
get that but I'm saying like it's better
than Ubi limited one time here's your
opportunity and then you get nothing to
complain about well I try to start my
business and failed okay well you had
your opportunity no Talent was lost
and maybe later in life you'll get more
wisdom and skill and talent and then
you'll succeed but you know we give
people a chance I guess
Ginger Vita says do you notice saki
keeps saying carrot or stick they're
using phrases treating us like animals
this originates from Churchill talking
about Nazis oof carrot stick I didn't
know that oh yeah
ham uh zinka says in a true Ubi system
we would all be paid the same regardless
of employment or not those who don't
work survive in poverty those who do are
rich having both the Ubi income and the
employment business income and then many
of those people who receive the Ubi
instead of spending it on rent or food
spend it on ho host Twinkies or drugs
and then we say we have a crisis of
people spending their money improperly
yes exactly I mean I can imagine it
occurring where and people are spending
this money either on Ho Ho's Twinkies
things that are not good for public
health so to speak or on things that the
media could say are bigoted or offensive
maybe they're supporting alternative
media Outlets with their money the way
some people did with their stimulus
checks and then it I think it starts to
become a matter of well do we need to
examine and give people Ubi like on the
basis of some kind of social credit
score I mean again that's extremely
hypothetical but I think it's within the
realm of possibility once the government
starts giving you money it's not as if
there are never strings attached to that
bug HQ says Supply prices up 30 percent
labor rates up 50 percent this war on
small business is ridiculous when I try
to talk to people about it all I hear is
crickets much like you'd get when you
buy from bug HQ did I do it right Mr
Michael Knowles happy birthday Lids bug
HQ we could use some crickets thrown to
the chickens oh yeah we're gonna have a
couple chicken babies hatching soon we
had some rotten eggs unfortunately yeah
there's bacteria in the egg I guess they
go bad oh that's tough yeah and they
were they were it's a couple weeks like
they were getting ready to hatch too and
had to pull them out but uh I think we
may have still five you know right
growing and maybe gonna hatch soon
that's why they lay so many eggs yeah
yeah
all right let's uh let's carry on my
good friends
I don't know what that Super Chat is in
reference to
um John Smith says in Starship Troopers
the Federation emerged naturally during
a time of great chaos where veterans
began banding together to stop looting
and riding huh interesting that sounds
good
seriously JK says I think you're all
forgetting about Free Enterprise in the
US decentralization will catapult the
exponential increase in economic
productivity creating a national black
market for counterfeit vaccine passports
defund my brain yeah that's um illegal
though
interestingly talk to your lawyer about
no I mean you should but my
understanding is it's only illegal if
you forge the CDC logo but with like I
guess with the the uh I don't know if
that would apply to the uh mobile apps
they do yeah I really think some hacker
is going to come up with a thing like
before it's going to be you know
all right let's see
Kevin Brady says I quit my welding job
to be a filmmaker full-time after three
years of working about 80 hours plus a
week I just negotiated a part-time
marketing job at my former employer you
can do it without College in fact I
recommend you do it without College good
for him honestly I love hearing that
someone you know like somebody going
after it I like it that's a risk and
good for him I like it for you actually
dude that's yes because follow it but
this has been on my mind a lot I feel
like the United States has become a
country of artists and like right sure
like so so I think there's definitely
been an argument to be made that welders
are more important than filmmakers but
we have a lot of filmmakers right now
putting out horrible ideas and we need
people producing media that's going to
represent positive values and also if it
is really the case that he was more
productive and valuable for society as a
welder he's not going to make money
making films and he'll go back to
welding but I think it's good for him
that he's trying but I really do what's
happening because he doesn't want to
look back on his life and think what if
what if I could have done this right
what if I could have contributed
something different that I would be more
passionate about contributing reading
and it never did so good for this guy
it's my I think it's more fun to create
art but like what we have as a country
of like people making movies and then
talking about it and complaining about
it and people writing stories about how
people are complaining about it and then
writing stories about them and like
we're all making money as we do it which
is this this fairy tale Fiat worthless
thing that we think is like numbers in a
bank account like what's the real value
the food's being imported the gasoline's
being imported like so I think there is
value to the Arts what happens is when
there is an economy which is robust and
well functioning enough for there to be
a lot of excess wealth then there are
people who can do things like be
political commentators or create movies
or television shows the things that
don't directly
increase the supply of basic necessities
and so I think you're right that an
economy can become lopsided at some
point but that's basically just what
bubbles are and so if there's a bubble
there it'll pop I would say again I
really want to continue to affirm this
guy because if the filmmaking thing
doesn't work out he has a very valuable
skill yeah he's not ever going to have
trouble getting a job as a welder though
I have said I would stop making
predictions about the future even the
past couple years so maybe I'm wrong
there maybe we just have this excess of
welders at some point and he should
stick to to uh filmmaking even if it
hasn't quite panned out just think about
how great it's going to be when we're a
nation of nothing but musicians and
filmmakers it's going to be fair
everyone's going to be a YouTuber
exactly everyone's starting a podcast
yeah well so this is exactly and this is
the problem when you have something like
Ubi it allows for a gargantuan bubble
the likes of which could never occur in
a Freer Market should have said that we
should print quadrillions of dollars to
pay for that did you hear him say that
it was a really quick and quiet he said
it as we were all talking and no one we
didn't really go into it but I was like
I want to pick his brain on that what
like how quadrillions of dollars yeah
because we were like we have we've
printed 20.
six zeros off their current maybe he was
joking he might have been joke he could
have been joking yeah you could have
misheard but he was saying in defense of
Ubi it was like print quadrillions I
don't I don't know I would I'd like to
ask him so the money is worth nothing
that's what would tend that was what
would happen welcome to Venezuela the
dollar would lose value so and again
even people who are proponents of this
mmt fantasy will tell you that in order
for inflation not to occur when you're
injecting copious amounts of currency
into the economy you have to have a very
productive economy and you need to reach
full employment basically and right now
we have just printed an insane amount of
money after shutting the economy down
for months at a time so let's see how
that works out again even the people who
have all these fantasies about us being
able to print whatever money we want
under an mmt structure uh could look at
something like this and say not going to
be great for the value of our dollar the
survival prepper says keep preaching
preparedness Tim our financial supply
chain and governmental issues may seem
small should the house Foreign Affairs
committee minority staff report about
China and the origins of coven
preparedness now is insurance for the
future that absolutely is yeah I mean uh
I think people who don't have some level
of just like emergency supplies are just
arrogant and stupid amen especially in
cities of all places yeah man Escape
From New York but I don't think I should
have a first aid kit water or food it's
like I'm not telling you to stock up and
fill up an underground bunker with 30
years of beans dude yeah I'm talking
about like what are you gonna eat when
it rains yeah a hurricane seriously
hurricane I got power in New York for a
couple weeks it was hard to get stuff
what did you eat like we're not saying
you have to though I actually wouldn't
advise against this but no one's saying
you know get get months or years of
emergency supply food though actually I
I would recommend that but it can even
just be a couple weeks it can really it
can really just be a couple weeks worth
of emergency supply food and let me add
the caveat if you have the financial
means where you're capable of doing so
whether without compromising having your
short term needs met you should get
months worth of emergency supply food
because it literally cannot hurt you to
have it but yeah it can even just be
like four weeks worth of emergency
supply food I just I don't understand
how anyone could be against that there
are people who will scoff at that idea
of being you know prepared with
emergency food and I just the the smooth
brain thinking there to me is just
unbelievable Delhi Opera says Ian
doesn't know what he's talking about the
lockdowns in Australia are nowhere near
as strict as what they had in CA and New
York not even close
yeah New York had checkpoints yeah like
you you couldn't even enter certain
places aren't people getting dragged out
of their houses in in Australia I don't
know if they're getting dragged into
their houses they're just like 10 months
ago for a Facebook post or something
that I think was in the UK
isn't isn't that considered part of the
UK Commonwealth I mean technically but
come on they're different countries are
you sure it wasn't Australia remember
that woman screaming and there was a
there was a woman who was like had a had
a mask exemption I thought people were
getting dragged out of their houses in
in Australia if I'm wrong about that I
apologize
I know in I think in Canada and and the
UK that happened Canada yeah Canada had
a rough too right now oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right let's just grab one more
let's see what we got here
um we'll just uh we'll wrap up on this
last one destiny Pratt says happy
birthday Lids mine's in two days thank
you oh happy birthday there you go all
right everybody follow us at timcast IRL
basically everywhere you can follow me
personally at timcast go to timcast.com
because we will have a bonus members
podcast coming up around 11 or so p.m
and uh you know sign up help support our
journalism you'll get an ad free
experience as well and the mainstream
media is clearly angry at the success
and expansion of our site we're going to
be launching a non-profit so I'm talking
with some lawyers about this like proper
formation we're going to create a
separate entity which is going to be
independent and we're going to hire fact
Checkers and the goal is to fact check
articles as well as take a random
sampling from different news
organizations and then run those
articles against the SBJ uh so these are
like the standard journalistic ethics
and then if they don't label opinion if
there's factual inaccuracies if they
don't uh uh uh address conflicts of
interest if they don't announce
Corrections and we can see manipulations
to the article vehicle these will get an
X then we'll do a random sampling of 100
articles from the past three months and
then we'll say x out of 100 are good so
you might see some you know click bait
leftist site getting a 30 out of 100
some conservative site getting a third
out of 100. the New York Times I think
would probably be like a 60 out of 100.
Huffington Post would probably be a zero
I mean that literally because I think
it's all opinion and unlabeled
you can't put up an article that is
opinion and not say its opinion and a
lot of these uh like websites do this so
Daily Beast and slate and Salon they
probably all be zeros just across the
board uh daily wire says it's an opinion
conservative you know and commentary but
you know we'll see as well because they
might actually get a zero two we'll see
um but uh Sheamus do you want to mention
anything yeah so just uh check me out
youtube.com freedomtunes that's
t-o-o-n-s we're going to be releasing a
cartoon tomorrow with Dr fauci in it
it's gonna be pretty funny also if you
are an animator looking for work
at Seamus Coughlin on Twitter that's
s-e-a-m-u-s underscore c-o-u-g-h-l-i-n
really easy if you want to just check
out it should be in the the link it
should be in the description of this uh
podcast but just reach out to me
um we're looking to bring people on the
team for Freedom tunes and also other
projects because I've mentioned my my
business is expanding so
great reach out thank you always a
pleasure to have you here Sheamus thank
you it's always a pleasure to be here uh
Tim Lydia thanks for thanks for coming
Lydia happy birthday thank you happy
birthday follow me Ian Crossland on the
internet I would love to see you on the
internet follow Ian on the internet
thank you guys so much for helping me
celebrate my birthday I think I've
worked every birthday of the last 10
years and this is the most special I
felt on my birthday you guys are more
than welcome to follow me on Twitter at
Sarah patch Lids I am closing in on Sour
Patch Kids I think I'm 10K away so let's
do it let's get her that birthday but
guys let's go to that birthday present
of beating Sour Patch Kids can we go
over there and like Lydia's Twitter can
we get can we give her a follow let's do
it yeah sure everybody do it see what we
can do thanks James you're welcome we
will see you all at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out